Ja, das Problem ist halt......GPG. Also wirklich so das Arschgeweih der Hacker-Szene. Diese hochnotparanoiden Aluhüte, die irgendwie jedes Social Network meiden, wie das Weihwasser, weil ja dein Netzwerk da abgebildet wird, aber dann Key-Signing-Partys machen.
Ich auch.
Gib noch mal her, das stimmt. Das liegt mir in der Hand, ne?
Ich find das gut.
Ich glaub gleich müssen wir wirklich mal hochgehen, weil irgendwie, ich hab auch so viel, die Decke geht immer einen Zentimeter runter, aber nur neun Millimeter wieder zurück.
So, na dann, viel Spaß. Boot mal.
Ja, geht ja nicht an, das Ding. Wo ist denn hier der Einschalter?
Willst du Ström haben?
Ich muss auch, der Unterschied zum, als ich das 5S bestellt hab, dann haben die das ja tatsächlich aus China geschickt und dann konntest du halt das tracken, wie das halt erst über Alma-Ata oder wie diese Stadt da jetzt heißt, keine Ahnung, die Stadt der Äpfel heißt das tatsächlich, geschickt wird und dann irgendwann hier in Köln ankommt, und von Köln dann irgendwie DHL und so weiter. Aber diesmal kam es irgendwie, wurde es gestern angekündigt, dass es versendet wird und dann haben sie es wohl über Prag irgendwie hierher gekutschiert und nicht mehr. Man konnte nicht mehr aus China tracken. Ne, aber früher war das so. Dann haben sie dir das echt gesagt, jetzt ist es aus China versandt und dann hast du das Tracking von China ausgesehen, wo es immer gerade ist, an welchen Zoll beherren, das ein- und ausgecheckt wird durch die ganzen Länder, da konntest du alles einzeln sehen. Das haben sie jetzt mal ein bisschen runtergefahren. Ne, das Mitte unten Modell. Ne, keine Ahnung, also das 64 Gig Modell hab ich genommen. Das mittlere.
Das reicht mir nicht.
Hast du doch auch?
Ne, ich hab 128. Ach so, ich hab alle zwei Jahre ein neues Gerät. Und just kurz vor Ablauf dieser zwei Jahre ist es denn echt voll. Ich hab jetzt in diesem Sommer das erste Mal irgendwelche komischen Videos mal runtergelöscht, die ich gemacht hatte mit der Kamera oder sowas, weil es ein bisschen rumgemauzt hat. Aber mein 5S war jetzt so knapp voll. Und dann verdoppeln sie den Speicher und dann reicht es immer wieder. Für zwei Jahre. Aber ich hab keinen Bock, das auszusortieren. Ich hab meine Fotos da drauf und Tralala und Musik und so. Und will das nicht immer rumsortieren.
Bei mir finde ich macht sie das auch sofort bemerkbar, weil es halt einfach zu groß.
Ich hoffe, es hat wehgetan. Mann, Mann, Mann.
Das sind die richtigen Fanboys, meinst du, ja?
Ja, wenn man da ein schönes Foto auf dem Film hat. Da dürfen wir jetzt nicht drüber reden. Also du tauchst jetzt erstmal in dein iPhone 6s.
Du kannst jetzt hier dein Feedback oder dein, was war das andere?
Follow-up.
Genau, das war's.
Ja, erstmal Feedback. Also erstmal hat Hokel irgendwie eine Menge Flagg bekommen, weil er keine Ahnung von Android hatten. Das war ja alles total falsch und ist ja auch alles ganz anders. Also anders als dargestellt ist das Telefon, das er da test hatte, nicht scheiße, sondern total geil.
Wir kriegen sowieso noch eine Ansage, weil wir jetzt jährlich über alte Apple-Sachen reden, anstatt über die brandneuen, gestern vorgestellten...
Das ist ja wieder ein Nexus, irgendwas mit einer Zahl, wo man nicht weiß, ob das jetzt der Bildschirm ist oder die Reihenfolge.
Nur mit ohne S, sondern mit P dran.
Bezeichnet das jetzt gerade die Bildschirmdiagonale oder bezeichnet das die Versionsnummer? Das weiß man ja bei denen immer nicht so genau.
Jetzt kann ich wieder ohne SIM nicht aktivieren hier. So, scheiße.
Ja, weiß nicht, sorry, aber mich macht's einfach... Ja, liebe Android-Fans, ja, meinetwegen, wir haben da nicht so eine Ahnung und überhaupt so...
Aber es tut uns auch nicht leid.
Ihr bräuchten mal so ein Android-Handbook, ihr kennt immer so ein paar Fragen.
Mich emotionalisiert Android einfach überhaupt null. Also da geht einfach nicht auch nur ein Funken irgendwie irgendwas auf mich über. Ich hab da noch nichts gesehen, wo ich mal gesagt hätte, wow! Und ich finde einfach die Gesamtsituation ist einfach katastrophal.
Du bist mit der Gesamtsituation unzuregelt.
Mit der Gesamtsituation? Für mich ist Android wie damals Windows. Und ich war damals schon nicht auf der Windows-Seite und ich hab das auch nicht vor zu sein jetzt, weil irgendwas irgendwie ist. Ich bin einfach ein großer Freund von Software und Hardware, ist aufeinander abgestimmt und fertig. Das fand ich schon immer geil.
Aber dann ist das doch alles nicht frei. Du verstehst das alles nicht, Tim.
Ja, ja. Wie ist das frei genug? Das beschützt mich auf jeden Fall mehr als dieser Android-Zoo für Viren und Malware.
Der SIM-Karten-Slot ist nicht kompatibel.
Was? Von 5S auf was?
Von 5S auf 6S erwartest du das?
Das kann man gerade schon rausnehmen aus dem Schieber.
Ich hab versucht jetzt mal den anderen Schieber reinzumachen. Na was, man muss alles mal austesten.
Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht groß rüber herziehen. Bis jetzt weiß ich nichts von dem. Mich tangiert das einfach nicht. Mich lässt das einfach kalt. Ich habe hier dieses Nexus 7 Tablett und ich lade da jedes Update, was mir angeboten wird. Ich klick drauf rum und es fühlt sich immer noch genauso bekloppt an wie vorher. Das mag jetzt nicht das top aktuelle Gerät sein und sicherlich auch nochmal was anderes als Tablett, aber es sieht aus wie Windows und es fühlt sich an wie Windows und ich will einfach kein Windows.
Ich hätte es jetzt nicht sagen sollen.
Na ist doch so. Allein die Icons, wie die schon aussehen. Ich meine sogar dieses Google-Logo hat ja sogar dieselben Farben wie Microsoft. Ich meine genau dieselben. Exakt dasselbe. Wo siehst du da einen Unterschied? Naja, aber ich habe ja auch Flak gekriegt, weil ich dummes Zeug erzählt habe zum Thema Fire TV. Sieh ich auch alles ein. Lustig ist, ich hatte so ein komisches Fire TV, diesen komischen Stick hatte ich hier tatsächlich schon seit Monaten rumliegen, weil ich mir das in so einem Effekt, die Dinger gab es glaube ich mal für 19 Euro oder so. Irgendjemand wies mich darauf hin und dann habe ich mir das geklickt und ich wusste gar nicht warum, da lag dieses Paket bei mir jetzt mehrere Monate rum, ungeöffnet. Weil es mir mit Amazon so ähnlich geht, so ein bisschen. Also es emotionalisiert mich auch nur so peripher. Ich kauf da eigentlich ganz gerne, aber so als Plattform ist mir das einfach zu creepy. Auf jeden Fall habe ich so ein Ding, dann habe ich es mal ausgepackt und mal benutzt und sehe da, ich hatte natürlich mit allem total unrecht. Ich glaube, das hatten wir auch schon die Ansatzweise schon korrigiert, so als Live-Feedback einrollte. Also tatsächlich hat das Ding halt so ein Android-App-Store dahinter und es gibt da auch Apps, es gibt da auch Spiele. Habe ich gesehen, habe sie jetzt nicht groß ausprobiert, weil ich jetzt auch keinen Game-Controller habe, sondern nur diese normale Fernbedienung. Und das Lustige ist ja, wenn du das Ding bestellst mit deinem Amazon-Account, also zumindest in meinem Fall, wo ich Amazon Prime hatte.
Da gibst du irgendwas umsonst, aber das hat mich auch nie angefixt, weil die denn keine englischen Turnspuren haben und all so ein Scheiß.
Auf jeden Fall, ich hab das Ding aus einer verschweißten Verpackung rausgenommen und das Ding war auf meinen Account vorprogrammiert. Ich musste da kein Passwort eingeben. Ich hab das Ding reingesteckt und das hatte meinen Prime-Account verkonfiguriert bereits. Was ich so nicht erwartet hätte. Alleins vom Packaging her schon mal ganz interessant, wenn man sich natürlich schon fragt, okay, das Ding wird dann während der Produktion programmiert oder später konfiguriert und dann steckt den jemand überhaupt erst in so eine Kiste rein und das klappt dann auch immer, dass es immer den Richtigen erwischt. Hat auf jeden Fall bei mir offensichtlich funktioniert. Dann ist es halt so ein komischer Stick, den du da reinsteckst, wo du dann aber an der Seite noch mal so ein USB-Kabel reinstecken musst, damit das Ding lädt. Dann hab ich irgendwie erstmal, genau, das ist einfach nur ein Micro-USB, da hatte ich erstmal das Kabel von einem anderen, von einem Apple-Netzteil genommen, da rein gesteckt. Da meinte das Marker nicht, weil das würde ihm nicht genug Strom liefern oder so, mich so ein bisschen gewundert hat, weil das war halt so ein 1A Netzteil, glaube ich, oder vielleicht sogar 2A, da kam definitiv genug Strom aus für das Teil. Dann hab ich halt das Original-Ding da reingesteckt und das hatte dann nur einen halben Ampere abgezogen. Ich hab so ein Messgerät dazwischen gesteckt, also da war jetzt kein besonderer Stromverbrauch, warum auch bei so einem kleinen Teil, aber damit wollte er dann auf jeden Fall laufen. Na ja, dann kann man halt so rumsarfen, kann sich irgendwie Filme angucken. Also in diesem Prime sind halt irgendwelche Filme drin. Das ist aber auch nicht alles, also du kannst halt dann trotzdem noch leihen und kaufen und das ganze Kram, weil es ist mehr nur so ein Teaser. Das ist halt so in deinem Prime mit drin. Ja, dann hast du halt so Apps für Mediathek und so. Das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt das, was uns jetzt in den nächsten Wochen dann für Apple TV auch alles erwartet. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass alles, was so mediathekmäßig unter der Sonne ist, sich sehr schnell auf dem Apple TV dann auch wiederfinden wird. Ja, und dann hatten sie auch wieder eine Liste mit so Top-Apps und da waren dann so Fireplace-Apps drin. Ich glaube, zwei oder drei von der Top-Liste waren so Fireplace. Scheint voll die heiße Gaming-Plattform zu sein. Also man kann es super dazu benutzen, seinen Fernseher in so einen Fireplace umzuwandeln.
Wenn man einen Fernseher hat. Andersherum geht es nicht. Ich habe so einen Fireplace. Ich habe versucht, da mal drauf irgendwie Sendungen mit der Maus zu gucken. Das ging nicht. Da musst du den Fireplace. Hab dann hinten irgendwann reingesteckt, das dann sofort weggeschmolzen.
Zu hoher Betriebstemperatur einfach. Hübsch war es jetzt nicht, diese Apps waren halt so komische Android Tablet Apps, die mich schon so auf dem Tablet nicht besonders angesprochen hätten und deren UI bedienst du dann halt irgendwie so mit links, rechts, oben, unten. Keine Ahnung, wie sehr die dann angepasst sind, aber bestenfalls nur so ein bisschen. Und... Leute meinten in den Kommentaren, dass das wohl mit diesem CEC, Remote-Control-Klimpen über HDMI auch durchaus funktionieren würde. Wenn du darüber Lautstärke oder sowas dann schickst, da gibt es ja sehr unterschiedliche Meinungen, ob dieser Teil des HDMI-Standards langsam, ob der wirklich gut funktioniert oder nicht, müsste er ja langsam mal, ist ja seit Anfang an Teil des Standards. Ich denke halt, gut meinetwegen, ich finde es trotzdem schade, ich würde halt lieber bei Amazon Prime einfach für meinen privilegierten Lieferkram zahlen und nicht jetzt unbedingt noch für so ein komischer Fernseh-Flatrate, die eh keine ist, weil sie eben nur ausgewählte Filme enthält.
Das ist halt Netflix aber dann auch wieder nicht...
Na Netflix gibts da auch drauf.
Keine englische, ja, aber...
Achso und die Filme, die dich ausgeladen haben, die kamen in deutscher und englischer Tonsprache, also zumindest bei den 1, 2, 3...
Als es damals rauskam, hab ich mir den angeguckt und gedacht, ne, jetzt hier nur irgendwelche komischen Synchro-Versionen von irgendwelchen Quack, da hab ich jetzt keinen Bock. Inzwischen haben sie das verstanden, ne?
Das ist aber auch ganz interessant. Also ich bin dann irgendwie an dieser Arte-App hängen geblieben, also quasi auch nur der Port von dieser Arte-Android-Tablet- Android-Mediathek-App so. Und dann bin ich gleich in so einer Doku hängen geblieben, die dann, als sie fertig war, gleich die nächste Doku abspielt, die ich mir dann auch gleich noch angeschaut hab. Weil die halt so interessant war. Ja genau, weil bei Arte kommt ja nun auch wirklich was Nennenswertes bei Rubber, insofern ist das ja eigentlich ganz nett. Zeigt schon, dass wenn man ohnehin schon in dieser Coach-Potato-Haltung ist und so mit der Fernbedingung in so einer Mediathek rumpuppeln kann, das schon ganz cool. Und vor allem, wenn mal dieser ganze Kinderkram noch dazukommt, also wird wahrscheinlich nicht lange dauern, dann hast du das ganze Kika-Sendung mit der Maus-Universum, etc. da auch vollständig. Also das gibt es auch teilweise hier schon. Also Kika hatte ich jetzt glaube ich nicht gefunden, aber so Sandmännchen und dieser ganze Kram, das findet sich da schon. Aber was halt hier auch wirklich fehlt, ist so ein überzeugendes, halbwegs einheitliches User-Interface. Also zumindest, dass du so das Gefühl hast, du kannst alles irgendwie auf dieselbe Art und Weise benutzen. Du benutzt es schon insofern auf dieselbe Art und Weise, dass es irgendwie schon mit Hoch, Runter, Links, Rechts geht, aber wie sich das dann so konkret ausprägt, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist ja eh so ein Problem. Ich hatte mir in diesem Frühsommer ja auch mal so ein Ding geklickt, so ein Plaste-Billo-Fernseh-Ding. Wenn du so willst. Ja, wie so ein fertig beschickter Raspberry Pi mit Infrarot-Fernbedienung oder so was. Und ein paar lustige Schnittstellen dran. Weil gibt's ja relativ billig so zu klicken auf Amazon, keine Ahnung, 50, 60 Euro. So für Internet-TV, ne? Und dann haben die da natürlich so eine Standardsoftware für diese Linux-Raspberry-Pi-Szene oder so was, die die da auch drauf haben. Ich komm jetzt gerade nicht auf den Namen. Das ist aber auch so ein Zoo. Also auch mit Plugins und hier und da. Und jedes Ding sieht anders aus. Ein fürchterliches Bedienkonzept. Versuchst du damit dann mit dieser Infrarot-Fernbedienung mit Cursor hoch, Cursor runter, rechts, links, OK-Taste, dich dadurch zu wurschteln, durch diese Zeugs. Das ist wirklich ganz, ganz bitter. Und ich glaube, daran scheitert es auch. Auf der einen Seite wollen die Leute natürlich gerne. Das ist so ein Plug-In-Konzept, dass jeder seinen Lieblingssender oder seinen Lieblings-Up da drin noch laufen haben kann. Aber das bringt natürlich so dieses ganze Bedienkonzept immer völlig durcheinander. Das war also wirklich echt kein Spaß. Ich hatte den jetzt nicht zum Fernsehen, ich hatte eh keinen Fernseher, sondern ich hatte erzählt, dass ich zur Republika so ein bisschen Multicast gemacht habe und dachte mir, naja, dann mal gucken, ob wir so ein Ding auch dazu bringen, unseren Republika-Kanal da oder unsere Kanäle da zu empfangen. Das haben wir dann auch geschafft, aber das war halt kein Spaß. Ich glaube, da musste ich noch viel tun in dieser Android-Szene oder so. Es läuft auch eng drauf, auf den Dingern. Und ich komme jetzt, wie gesagt, wirklich nicht. Ich verstehe mir gerade noch in dieser Name von dieser so eine Fernseh-Home-TV, Home-Video-Engine. Egal, der Chat weiß das bestimmt.
Also ich meine, man muss halt jetzt mal schauen. Ich werde mir dieses Apple TV auf jeden Fall kaufen, weil mich das einfach interessiert. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe ja hier allein schon deshalb eins im Studio einfach nur so als Airplay-Ausspielgerät. Das ist für mich schon die Investition absolut wert gewesen. Also zumindest diese Investition in die, was ich damals bezahlt, jetzt kostet es, glaube ich, 69, das kleine, damals wahrscheinlich 99. Ich bin gespannt, wie sich das so manifestieren wird. Ich glaube aber, dass da einfach durch diesen iOS-Store, oder halt diesen TV-OS-Store, dass das einfach eine Menge Wumms hat, vor allem im Spielebereich. Also diese ganze Casual-Gaming-Geschichte, die wieder hinkommt. Und dann gab es hier schon so ein erstes Video, dass jemand den MAME-Emulator da drauf gebracht hat, und das fände ich auch geil. Also so vor seinem Fernseher sitzen und dann irgendwie so schön die original MAME-ROMs, so das original Donkey Kong, original der ganze Kram. Klar kann man halt irgendwie auch am Rechner machen, aber das ist dann halt schon mal was anderes, wenn du einfach nur Fernbesienungen stark anschalten und ab geht er, der Peter. Für die 8-Bit-Generation.
So, wie geht's dir so, Denis? Denis, willst du auch mal da runter?
Ich installiere jetzt Rear Store from iTunes mit dem Phone. Ich muss jetzt sozusagen meinen ganzen Staff da rüberkloppeln.
Hast du vorher schon ein Backup gemacht gehabt?
Ja, sicher.
Clemens, kleiner Tipp. Es gibt ja immer wieder Applikationen, die haben aus manchmal wichtigen Gründen, manchmal aus eher banalen Gründen, haben die keinen Bock darauf, ihre Informationen, ihre Daten, in diesen Storage abzulegen, der auch mit Backup wird. Zum Beispiel die tolle… Streamer. Streamer. Ja, du musst es aber extra machen. Du musst in deine Streamer-Applikation auf deinem alten Telefon gehen. Du kannst es aber auch als guter Grund, dein altes Telefon noch eine Weile zu behalten. Da kannst du aber einen noch platzieren. Ich hab ja nur reichlich Sims, aber wenn du irgendeine alte Gammelsim hast, da rein machen, dass dein Telefon nicht da und da mal rumkriegt, dass es kein Sim hat, das kann ich nicht erträgen, dass es kein Netz hat mit dem Sim. Das ist okay. Aber so ein iPhone ohne Sim, das fühlt sich gar nicht wohl. Also machst du irgendeine alte SIM-Karte da rein, ob die geht oder nicht, ist egal. Und dann kannst du zum Beispiel bei Trema über so einen QR-Code, den du mit dem anderen Telefon wieder abfotografierst, kannst du da deinen Key übertragen. Aber sowas muss man halt vorher machen. Und man muss wirklich sich jede Applikation da angucken. Speichert die jetzt ihre Daten in den Store, in den Backup mit oder nicht? Da hab ich auch ganz überraschende Ergebnisse gehabt schon, wo ich auch dachte, das ist jetzt nicht geheim, weil du da hast deinen Settings, warum musst du das jetzt neu eingeben?
Bei Streamer ist es so schwierig, dass man von vielen Leuten nur zwei IDs hat, dass man die parallel auf dem Ding hat, weil die das nicht richtig gemacht haben. Dann fangen sie einfach mit einem neuen an.
Es ist ja relativ. Also theoretisch hätte man das einfach mit abspeichern können. Aber jetzt machen sie halt einen super wichtig, sicher. Aber die Idee, dass du auf dem alten Telefon den QR-Code anzeigst, mit dem neuen Telefon abfotografierst, dann hat sich das auch schon okay, finde ich. Also das ist jetzt nicht beyond feasible. Aber da sollte man sich wirklich die Applikation vorher nochmal angucken und sagen so, ja, wie kriege ich die eigentlich rüber?
Also gibt es noch ein bisschen Live-Berichterstattung von deinem iPhone 6?
Nee, der Balken kriegt es noch nicht.
Ich kann ja nochmal sagen, wie meine iOS 9-Erfahrungen waren. Die waren nämlich nicht gut. Also meine Install-Erfahrung.
Install-Erfahrung. Ach, bist du in diesem Bug hängen geblieben? Echt? Aber der soll doch nur gekommen sein, wenn man direkt von 7 auf 9 geblieben hat.
Stimmt nicht. Das mag da noch häufiger sein. Also ich hatte drei Geräte, ein iPad 3, ein iPad Mini 2 und ein 5S-iPhone. Die ich alle auch von 8 auf 9 gebracht habe. Kein Problem. Ohne Betakram. Bei meinem iPad 3 hatte ich diesen beschriebenen Fehler, der angeblich mit 9.01 behoben sein soll. Das heißt, der kam danach in dieses Setup-Tool und nichts passierte. Da konnte ich halt gar nichts mehr machen. Bei meinem iPad Mini 2 und bei meinem iPhone hatte ich den Effekt, dass die nach der Installation, wobei das jetzt erst mal so durchlief und ich diesen ganzen Anmeldungs-Klimb im machen konnte, nur dass das Ding natürlich nicht mehr ins WLAN eingebucht hat. Das war so überhaupt nicht so. Ausgeschaltet, angeschaltet, rebooted, alles Mögliche probiert, dass die Dinger waren irgendwie kaum zu überzeugen. Allerdings, wenn man dann so, ich weiß nicht, bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob das eher was mit Warten zu tun hatte, also ob das Problem dadurch einfach verschwand, indem es einfach ein paar Stunden in Ruhe gelassen wird, oder ob ich es tatsächlich mit meinen Reboot-Orgien, mit lange 10 Sekunden drücken und Hardreset und so weiter, ob ich es damit ein bisschen in die Knie gezwungen habe, weiß ich nicht, aber irgendwann war das Problem dann auf meinem iPad Mini 2 auch weg. Nur mein iPhone 5S nervt mich jetzt eigentlich seit einer Woche. Und ich kann auch nicht genau sagen, wodurch das ausgelöst wird. Manchmal ist das einfach so morgens, so zum Aufstehen, voll geladen. Manchmal hatte ich das Gefühl, dass es was mit diesem Stromsparmodus zu tun hatte. Also aber auch da ging er dann einfach nicht ins WLAN. So gar nicht. Und ich konnte, und das war dann auch nicht nur, dass er sich nicht einbuchte, sondern wenn ich auch nur in irgendetwas reinging, was in irgendeiner Form mit Networking zu tun hat, so wie WLAN-Settings aufrufen oder eine App aufrufen, die irgendwie Internet macht, auch wenn er gerade nicht im WLAN ist, hing immer alles. Also Safari startet, versucht irgendwie, Internetkommunikation zu betreiben, hängt, wird vom System weggekillt, so was. Verschwindet dann halt nach ein paar Stunden wieder. Also vollkommen erratisches, merkwürdiges Verhalten, was ich jetzt auch mit 901 wieder gehabt habe. Also das hat sozusagen daran jetzt noch nichts gemacht. Komischerweise haben da nicht so viele Leute drüber berichtet. Es war auch so absurd, du konntest auch WLAN nicht ausschalten oder so. Also auch dieser Knopf, mach mal deinen WLAN aus, ließ sich nicht aktivieren. Also es war so richtig ganz merkwürdig gebrickt. Aber hat sich dann sozusagen irgendwann wieder von alleine gefangen. Vollkommen komisch.
Die sind hinter dir her, ich sag's dir.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Nee, hatte ich gar nicht. Ich hab ja mal so eine Generation zurück, da hab ich 4S, 5S geupdatet, iPad, Easy Peasy. Null Probleme. Und jetzt auch 5S, 6S, iPad. Selbst das 4er, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, das 4er hab ich dann nochmal gelöscht. Richtig, weil ich jetzt sozusagen, ich hab ja immer die letzte Generation, das 4S hab ich jetzt weitergegeben, hab ich vorher nochmal gelöscht. Das war sogar wieder ganz fluffig, wenn es so leer war mit iOS 9 drauf. Im Gegensatz zu iOS 8 war es ja schon so ein bisschen, naja, gemächlich. Aber nee, finde ich jetzt okay, hab jetzt bisher nichts Großartiges zu mollen.
Naja, ich wollte es nochmal gesagt haben, ich bin jetzt mal gespannt. Jetzt haben sie ja wahrscheinlich den Braten schon gerochen und jetzt direkt zur Sendung die 902 rausgehauen.
Die wussten, dass du das bringst.
Und da stehen schon so Sachen drin. Unter anderem steht da drin, dass auch die Stabilität von Podcasts verbessert wurde.
Das haben wir am Anfang dieser Sendung nicht gemerkt.
Nee, da war es auch noch nicht ganz durchinstalliert. Aber jetzt ist glaube ich alles in Ordnung.
Nächste Freak Show ohne Gebastel am Mischpult vorne?
Ohne Echo.
Hast du die App überhaupt schon mal benutzt in iOS 9?
Welche?
Die Podcast-App.
Achso, nicht sehr.
Kannst du also gar nicht sagen, ob es stabiler geworden ist?
Nee, kann ich nicht sagen. Ich verwende die selten, auch wenn ich das vielleicht häufiger machen sollte. Irgendwann wollte ich ja auch mal wirklich noch mal alles so richtig schön... Aber ich hab sie schon ein bisschen gestartet und bin ein bisschen mit rumgefuhrwerkt und sie haben sie verbessert. Also es ist definitiv interessanter geworden.
Aber so einen Clean-And-Store kann man im iOS gar nicht machen, oder? Also du kannst schon einen Clean-And-Store machen, aber dann ist alles weg und du musst mit allem von vorne anfangen. Aber du kannst nicht sagen, für diese App jetzt würde ich jetzt gerne mal frisch von vorne anfangen. Das geht gar nicht, oder?
Es ist ohnehin schwierig, hab ich festgestellt, abslos zu werden.
Na, wenn du eine App löscht, dann wird ja auch der ganze...
Okay, man löscht sie, dann installiert man sie wieder und dann müsste es so gehen. Der fragt dann ja dann, ob er die Daten mitlöschen soll.
Eine App dauerhaft loszuwerden ist übrigens nicht einfach.
Ja, er sagt, dass es dann dauerhaft weg ist.
Ich stelle da so eine Frage, ob du sicher bist, dass du die Daten weghaben willst.
Ja, er sagt dann, wenn du die jetzt löscht, verschwinden doch alle Einstellungen, alle Daten, diese ab mit. Sagt er dir immer. Aber das kannst du jetzt nicht auswählen. Sagt er dir einfach. Aber noch mal, ich möchte zum dritten Mal sagen, du hast schon mal versucht, ein App richtig loszuwerden. Ihr habt euch mal eine App runtergeladen, die ist so richtig scheiße, denkst du, die will ich auch nie wieder sehen.
Die kommt dann immer wieder, ne?
Ja, weil du musst sie wirklich, wenn du mehrere Geräte hast, auf deinem Laptop, glaube ich, von Hand rausprepeln, sonst kommt die immer wieder. Ich wäre ja okay damit, wenn der App so aus sich merkt, dass ich die schon mal gekauft habe, oder auch für null gekauft habe, dann denke ich sozusagen, noch mal runterladen kann. Aber jetzt, ich will sie runter haben auf dem scheiß Telefon, nicht bei der nächsten Synchronisation wieder drauf haben. So, das ist irgendwie noch so ein bisschen schräg. Das war das.
Weiteres Feedback hatten wir dann noch zu Kleinkraben. Vor allem gab es ja, wie auch von David im Intro, schön abgefeiert, eine kleine Diskussion rund um GPG. Ich habe da ja ein bisschen geratet. Hast du die Sendung eigentlich gehört?
Nicht komplett, aber den Teil habe ich mir angeklickt.
Und? Hab ich Scheiß erzählt?
Nö, nicht wesentlich. Also ich habe nur relativ kleine Kerben im Lenkrad. Für den GPG-Teil auch gar nicht so groß. Eher so für diese ganze Rumraterei bezüglich Zertifikate und MIME und SMIME und so.
Genau, da habe ich dann auch etwas geeiert. Aber du darfst gerne da mal hinein.
Das hätte ich jetzt aufarbeiten müssen. Aber gab es so ein paar Sachen, also SMIME, ja, welche Zertifikate, irgendwas war da, wie ihr gesagt habt, jemanden diese Zertifikate...
Na ja, man muss halt erst mal eins haben. Das ist relativ easy. Na, was heißt relativ easy? Gehe auf eine skurrile Webseite, die so aussieht, als ob sie dir auch Drogen verkaufen würde und versuchst natürlich nur, der Face zu verstehen.
Muss gar nicht. Es gibt zum Beispiel manche Zertifikatsverwalter, wie zum Beispiel die auch von dir erwähnten SSL-Zert. Also...
Habe ich das erwähnt nicht? Start-SSL habe ich besser erwähnt.
Start-SSL meine ich gar nicht. Start-SSL, die identifizieren dich als Benutzer mit deinem Client-Certificate. Weil, das wissen wenige Leute, aber man kann das auch in seinem Browser benutzen, um sich zu identifizieren, anstatt immer Usernamen und Passwörter einzuhacken. So ein nettes Client-Certificate. Und dieses Client-Certificate, das müssen sie dir natürlich ausstellen. Und dieses Client-Certificate ist netterweise auch gleichzeitig für E-Mail verwendbar. Das heißt, du gehst halt einfach hin, gehst dahin zu Start-SSL, meldest dich da einfach an. Du kannst ja den niedrigsten Level machen, ohne Überprüfung, kostet also kein Geld. Du kriegst deinen Client-Certificate, das geht dir 1 oder 2 Jahre oder so was. Und das kannst du schon mal für E-Mail benutzen. Du kannst ohnehin jede Menge Zertifikate, kannst auch selber generierte Zertifikate benutzen für E-Mail. Dann schreit halt der beim Empfänger das erst mal auf und sagt er, ja, das ist wirklich Tim und dann ist gut. Wenn einmal der Zertifikat im Store landet und der Empfänger gesagt hat, ja, das ist Tims Zertifikat, ist scheißegal, wo das herkommt, wer das unterschrieben hat. Das ist ja der Punkt, den ich gesagt habe, wenn wir mal Crypto for the masses machen, wo wir uns dann darüber mal unterhalten können, was bedeutet Zertifikat, was ist für die Sicherheit zuständig und was ist für das Vertrauen zuständig und so weiter und so fort. Das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Punkt, der mir fehlte bei dieser ganzen Diskussion über Certificate Pinning. Habt ihr euch ja auch unterhalten. Man muss jetzt mal verstehen, wenn eine App mit ihrem eigenen Server redet, dann würde ich zum Beispiel einfach da mein eigenes Zertifikat hinterlegen und fertig. Gar nicht mit CAs oder sonst was, beziehungsweise mit meiner eigenen CA arbeiten vielleicht, für den Fall, dass ich sozusagen mal mein Zertifikat, was auf dem Webserver liegt, austauschen muss. Aber das ist ja meine App, die mit meinem Server redet. Da brauch ich keine Verix sein für oder keinen Start SSL oder sonst was, das kann ich einfach so machen. Damit hätte man diese Thema zum Beispiel auch erschlagen, dann kann man einfach sagen, okay, ich truste allem, was mir meine eigene CA unterschrieben hat. Nur für diese App. Diese ganze Geschichte mit den öffentlichen CAs ist ja immer nur dann da oder dann spannend, wenn ein Unbekannter, ein mit dir bisher Unbekannter das erste Mal Kontakt aufnimmt zu deinem Server oder du mit einem anderen. Weil dann gibt es sozusagen die Idee, dass man sagt, man kennt sich ja gegenseitig nicht, man hat ja noch nie miteinander zu tun gehabt und deswegen nimmt man einen vertrauenswürdigen Dritten, den nun netterweise die Firma Microsoft, die Firma Google oder die Firma Apple für dich ausgesucht hat, nämlich diese paar hundert CAs, die sie jetzt glauben, die sind alles schick, denen darfst du vertrauen. Aber der technische Mechanismus ist deswegen nicht kaputt, sondern nur der politische Mechanismus. Und den brauchst du, wie gesagt, auch nur, wenn zwei bis dato unbekannte Leute miteinander kommunizieren. Was für die Apps, die mit ihrem eigenen Backendserver reden, nicht zutrifft, deswegen brauchen wir diese Diskussion da gar nicht zu führen. Aber okay, wie gesagt, da müsste man jetzt mal auf die Details eingehen. Du weigst die Freak Show der falsche Ort dafür.
Aber was hindert denn zum Beispiel Apple da dran? Oder meinetwegen auch alle anderen Mail-Anbieter, so ein Krypto-Zertifikat für die E-Mail-Adressen, die sie ausgeben, auch zu provide? Warum kriege ich jetzt bei Gmail nicht für meinen Gmail-Account auch gleich ein Zertifikat?
Könnten sie machen. Google ist ja sogar eine CA. Könnten sie sogar richtig dir das Ding unterschreiben, wenn du das haben willst. Aber die hindert die nicht.
Dann könnten die das machen und dann können sie das auf ihrem Webmail machen?
Ja, der Mechanismus ist ja auch dafür da. Also zum Beispiel eine Krücke war lange Zeit. Die Frage mit dem Private Key. Die ganze Sicherheit basiert ja auf dem Private Key. Das hat ja nichts damit zu tun, wer dir das Ding unterschreibt oder nicht. Sondern der Private Key, der ist ein öffentliches Pendant, in dem Zertifikat drinsteckt. Der muss irgendwo erzeugt werden bei dir und bei dir auch bleiben. Und das heißt jetzt hinzugehen als großer Anbieter und zu sagen, ach, das ist alles so komplex. Das generiere ich dir einfach. Hier haste ist Kack. Weil du weißt eben nicht, ob die diesen Key sich selber noch irgendwo behalten. Das ist nicht vertrauenswürdig. Vertrauenswürdig ist es immer nur so, wenn du dir deinen Private-Public-Key-Pair selber generierst, dann den Public-Teil auf deinen Zertifikatsantrag draufklebst, das jemandem hingibst, das ein Stempel drauf macht, dann ist gut. Und dass dein Private Key dich dein Gerät niemals verlässt. Dafür gibt es aber schon seit etlichen Jahren einen Mechanismus, der so funktioniert, den zum Beispiel auch Start SSL benutzt, um dir deine kleine Zertifikate zu erzeugen. Du kannst nämlich deinen Browser bitten. Es gibt so HTML-Mechanismen, glaube ich, oder irgendwelche HTML-Exchanges, wo man dem Browser sagen kann, generiere noch mal bitte einen Private- und Public-Key-Pair. The Private Key merkst du dir, und der Public Key, das gibst du mir mal rüber. Und das heißt, damit kann man es halt machen, dass jeder für sich selber seinen Private Key erzeugt, den Public Key an eine Zertifizierungsinstanz gibt, die man dann auf ein Zertifikat draufpackt und unterschreibt. Das wäre sozusagen möglich. Und es gibt dann so Mechanismen, die dir zum Beispiel wieder hinterher zusammenmatchen. Also dein Browser generiert den Private Key, auf dem Apple speichert den in die Keychain. Und wenn du dein Zertifikat zurückkriegst, unterschrieben von irgendjemanden, dann hast du den Private Key schon dazu. Wenn du das auch in die Keychain packst, hast du sozusagen das komplette Paket, was man braucht. Das gibt es schon. Aber offensichtlich glauben die Leute, dass dieser Weg immer noch zu komplex ist für die Leute. Zum Beispiel selbst bei dem, ich mache ja seit Anfang des Jahres Zwangs-S-MIME für alle meine Kommunikationspartner. Ich signiere gnadenlos alles, mindestens. Auf allen Geräten, auf allen iPads, iPhones, Rechner, jede Mail, die ich verschicke, ist signiert von mir. Mal gucken. Das habe ich davor nicht gemacht, weil es davor immer noch irgendwelche Nasen gab, das hatte ich, glaube ich, in der Freak Show auch erzählt, weil es irgendwelche Nasen gab, die irgendwelche Mailer benutzt haben, die denn damit nicht klarkamen, dass da zum Beispiel noch irgendwie, da ist dann so eine Signatur dran und was soll denn das? Das ist ja eine Mail, die ist da ein S7P-Anhängsel dran oder so was, oder P7S oder so. Und habe ich jetzt seit Anfang des Jahres gesagt, mir ist scheißegal, wenn du einen kaputten Mailer hast, hast du einen kaputten Mailer, ist nicht mein Problem. Ich schicke jetzt gnadenlos alle signiert. Das heißt, ich verstreue damit auch mein Public Key. Automatisch. Da war ja auch so eine Diskussion, die ihr hatte zu GPG, wie verteilen wir diese Dinge über irgendwelche Key-Server und so was. Das passiert bei SMA mehr anders. In dem Moment, wo ich sozusagen das signiere, ist ja mein Zertifikat mit dran, da ist mein Public Key mit drin. Das heißt, du hast jetzt schon meinen Public Key. Wenn du mir jetzt was schicken willst, musst du dir selber nur noch einen Key zulegen, erkläre ich auch gleich warum, dann kannst du mir eine verschlüsselte Nachricht schicken und fertig.
Deine Mail ist tatsächlich gesigned und du hast ein Zertifikat von StartCom, also von dem Start SSL Freunden.
Das gibt es nicht nur von denen, das gibt es auch von anderen, nämlich wie hießen die denn nicht, ich will immer versuchen zu sagen, Yahoo, das ist aber nicht Yahoo, wie waren denn die mit diesem Hund, die hier in Deutschland mit diesem Hund geworben haben? Die hatten sogar Fernsehwerbung, keine Ahnung, mit so einer Schauspielerin und dann so einem großen Hund.
Also ich habe hier irgendwelche Keys von Start, SSL und ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich mich jetzt damit irgendwie...
Komodo gab es doch auch mal. Und Komodo ist auch so eine Bude, die gibt dir auch, ja Lykos schreibt gerade noch jemand, Lykos, Komodo und so. So aus der Anfangszeit dieser ganzen Internet-Hype-Geschichte. Und ein paar von den Buden gibt es immer noch, da gibt es Komodo und da schreibt dir auch ein Kleincertifikat für E-Mail umsonst. Kannste also haben. Ja, wie die auch sagen, das habe ich jetzt, ich signiere jetzt gnadenlos alles und ich kriege übrigens ernsthaft, und das ist kein Witz, ich kriege sogar von der Telekom, ich kriege verschlüsselte Mails. Es ist mein verschlüsselter Mail jetzt. Weil die aber Schweinkram machen, glaube ich, bei denen unterschreibt es der Server, da haben wir vorher schon auch eine schöne Klartext-Kopie, dessen hat, was seine Mitarbeiter mir schreiben. Oder sowas, aber immerhin, durch große böse Internet oder sowas kommuniziere ich mit der Telekom verschlüsselt, mit S-Mail, und zwar ohne, dass ich mit Admins dort diskutieren musste. Auch auf iPhone, aber um darauf zurückzukommen. Nehmen wir an, du hast es jetzt geschafft, dir so ein Zertifikat und ein Schlüsselpaar zu generieren, dann musst du das noch auf die Geräte drauf kriegen. Und da könnte zum Beispiel der Apple durchaus noch ein bisschen mehr von seiner, keine Ahnung, iCloud-Magic oder sonst was reinbringen. Weil das ist zum Beispiel ein ziemlicher Film, diese Dinger auf dein Telefon zum Beispiel zu bringen. Auch das ist übrigens eine Sache, die beim Update, also beim Wechsel von Telefon A zu Telefon B nicht mit übertragen wird, komischerweise. Ich musste meine ganzen S-MIME-Zertifikate und Keys musste ich von Hand wieder auf das iPhone 6S rüber spielen.
Wenn ich noch mal kurz zurückspulen darf, ich hab jetzt gerade mal parallel versucht, mir mal in diese Start-SSL-Ecke reinzukommen, wo ich mir sowas machen lassen könnte. Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr so richtig, wie das gelaufen ist, aber ich hatte irgendwann mir mal so für ein Domain bei Start-SSL tatsächlich so ein Zertifikat geholt.
Guck doch mal deinen Keychain, ob du noch ein kleines Zertifikat hast.
Ich hab jetzt hier in so einem Krypto-Ordner ein Key von Start-SSL, also abgesehen jetzt von den Keys, die ich für die Domain bekommen habe, also von den Zerts, die ich dafür bekommen habe, hab ich von Start-SSL. Das ist wahrscheinlich das, was du meinest, womit ich mich sozusagen als User wieder identifiziere. Ein Punkt P12 und eine Punkt PEM-Datei.
P12 ist ein Container, so was wie so ein TAR-File, ein verschlüsselter TAR-File, ne, ein TAR-File, was mehrere Sachen enthalten kann. Zum Beispiel Zertifikat, Public Key und Private Key gleichzeitig. Dass du nicht diese drei Teile immer, oder eigentlich sind es ja nur zwei Teile. Eigentlich hast du immer nur ein Zertifikat, weil das enthält ja schon den Public Key und du hast einen Private Key. Wenn du das zusammen transportieren willst, zum Beispiel von deinem Mac auf deinem Telefon, dann ist das besser, ich hab's an einer Datei. Dann schickst du dir das als P12-Datei und diese P12-Datei, wenn man die erzeugt, wird regelmäßig verlangt, dass du eine Passphrase oder so was mit reinmachst. Dass du sozusagen nicht auf dem Transportweg dir jemand klaut und damit Quack macht. Das heißt, du generierst dir so ein P12, gibst eine Passphrase ein, abc4711, schickst sie an dein Telefon als Attachment, an dein Mail dran oder zum Beispiel, dann gehst du auf deinem Telefon drauf.
Aber ich muss jetzt ja überhaupt erst mal meine eigene Keychain hier kriegen.
Dann klickst du einfach doppelt drauf.
Ja, und dann gebe ich meine Passphrase ein, und dann sagt er in Error, also gehört an, able to import an item. Fertig.
Dann guck doch mal, wo du das hin importieren wolltest. Wolltest du das vielleicht in die Root-Keychain importieren oder so was, dann ist da ein bisschen zickig.
The contents of this item cannot be retrieved, Malta.
Guck doch mal, ob die Datei vielleicht 0 bytes groß ist oder so, der Klassiker oder so. Ja, 2Ks, okay. Ja, dann stimmt deine Passphrase vielleicht nicht. Also ich mach das die ganze Zeit, das geht. Wenn ich den Passphrase falsch eingebe, sagt er... In unserem Podcast Crypto for the masses zeige ich dir auch noch, wie man diese Dinger noch schön verwaltet. Es gibt nämlich ein lustiges Tool dafür, das kann ich dir jetzt schon verraten, nämlich namens XCA, das kannst du schon mal runterladen. Für den Mac? Für alle Möchenplattformen. Wird dir wieder nicht gefallen, weil es wieder so crossplattformmäßig aussieht, ist aber okay auf dem Mac, ist jetzt nicht schlimm. Und damit kannst du deine ganzen Schlüssel verwalten, deine CAS verwalten und dein ganzes... benutze ich seit Jahren, das ist ein ganz hervorragendes Tool dafür. Und das generiert halt eben auch alle Möchenformate. Da kannst du halt, weiß ich, ein Zertifikat und ein Key separat reinschmeißen und das zusammen wieder als P12 exportieren und so weiter. Pkcs12.
Ja, irgendwie hat das hier nicht funktioniert. Da war ich nämlich schon mal. Ich hab mich schon mal versucht da einzuloggen und ich konnte halt mit diesen Keys nichts anfangen, die sie mir gegeben haben. Also kann ich das nur sozusagen nochmal von vorne machen, den ganzen Scheiß weg.
Das kann man ja auch nochmal zusammen machen. Aber das funktioniert eigentlich regelmäßig ganz gut. Aber das ist wie gesagt so ein Thema. Ja, aber das ist doch so schiste.
Noch nicht mal ich bin in der Lage, irgendwie mir so einen Scheiß zu geben. Warum kriege ich nicht in iCloud?
Ja, hast du sogar schon. Wenn du iCloud oder irgendwas benutzt, die benutzen andauernd Zertifikate, diese speziell für dich generieren, zum Beispiel für das Pushen von Nachrichten, hat dein Telefon lauter Zertifikate, den ganzen Tag.
Ich frage mich, was hält Apple eigentlich davon ab? Ich meine, sie können ja auch diese kleinseitige Generierung wunderbar machen.
Vielleicht der Typ von der NSA mit der Knarre, der hinter einem Entscheider da steht oder so. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber technisch gesehen gibt es keine Gründe, weil sie machen es andauernd. Apple weist dir automatisch Zertifikate zu und so weiter und so fort. In der Stelle könnte es auch genauso gut hingehen und sagen, hier komm, hast du eine Zertifikate. Aber ich denke, was sie nicht machen wollen werden, aus verschiedenen Gründen, ist, dass sie sagen, ja, wir unterschreiben dir gerne deine tim.pritloff.at icloud.com Adresse, aber wir unterschreiben dir nicht deine tim.pritloff.at org.adresse.
Nee, das ist schon klar. Aber zumindest, wenn man jetzt so ein iCloud-User ist und tatsächlich diese iCloud-E-Mail-Adresse verwenden will, was ja sicherlich viele auch tun. Was hält Apple mit ihrer Infrastruktur davon ab? Auch noch dieses kleine i-Tüpfelchen. Du kannst deine Mails jetzt auch verschlüsseln, weil du hast hier eine Mail-App, die ist in der Lage, dir den Key das erste Mal zu erzeugen und dann automatisch das zu submitten.
Und dann gibt es dann ein paar Worte an.
Und dann ist es in der Keychain, dann syncst du es über iClouds Keychain sowieso auch alles und dann ist es doch fertig oder nicht?
Das hätte ich eigentlich noch mal ausprobieren sollen. Ich habe den Mechanismus schon drin, bevor es iCloud Keychain gab. Aber ich könnte jetzt noch mal ausprobieren, mal ein Zertifikat da reinzumachen, um mit Private Key und sowas in die iCloud Keychain und zu gucken, ob das dann noch auf den Telefon auftaucht, ob ich den da benutzen kann. Das wäre mal eine interessante Sache. Das wäre amtlich. Ja, denn vieles fehlt nur noch daran, dass die Mail ab, die ihr beim ersten Starten sagt, komm lass uns doch mal lustige Zertifikat generieren. Und das wäre eigentlich schon cool.
Also könnten sie machen, ne? So sehe ich das nämlich eigentlich auch, weil mir bloß nicht so ganz sicher ist, ob ich nicht irgendwas übersehen habe. Für Google ist es wiederum nicht so einfach.
Ein ganz wichtiger Punkt ist, du generierst dir deinen Private Key.
Ja, ist schon klar, aber wie macht man...
Du lässt dir nicht von anderen Leuten einen Private Key generieren.
Ja, aber wie macht das Gmail dann? Und wie machen sie das im Web?
Das ist das, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Du kannst halt deinen Browser dazu bringen, dass er einen Key Pair generiert, den Public-Teil an den Server schickt, damit er da irgendwelche Zertifikate draus macht und den Private Key bei dir lässt. Das ist zum Beispiel das Start SSL auf ihrer Seite machen. Und das können auch Firefox und so weiter. Das ist ein Standard. Frag mich nicht, ich bin kein HTML-Hacker, da können bestimmt jetzt Leute nachgucken und sagen, ja, das ist dieses HTML5-Element oder HTML3.4-Element oder wie man will. Scheißegal, das gibt jetzt schon eine Weile, das Ding, dass du sozusagen ein Input-Formular generieren kannst, wo der Browser einen Key Pair generiert und den Public Key automatisch in den Formular reinmacht, den Private Key in deine Keychain oder sonst wo hin speichert. So, und damit kannst du halt eben alle möglichen webbasierten Key Pair-Certificate-Mechanismen etablieren.
Tja, aber wir müssen alle noch warten.
Da fehlt ja immer noch da dran so ein bisschen.
Ein Elend.
So, der Kapitän wollte hier nicht runterladen. Wegen Error.
Jetzt lese ich hier schon wieder im Chat, ist mein Mal auch mehr für Organisationen. Nein, Leute, versteht das bitte. Wir müssen diesen anderen Podcast-Show machen.
Ja, machen wir auch.
Da ist so viel Fehlinformation, was sich da immer rumtreibt oder so. Und diese Zertifikate wird immer so, ja, das ist nur was für Windows-Admins. Und was nicht schon allen für einen Scheiß gehört habe dazu.
Nicht?
Das Interessante ist, dass dieser Standard, diese Grundidee, wenn man das verstanden hat, das taucht in alle Möglichkeiten wieder auf. Das taucht in VPNs wieder auf. Du kannst ja eine Witz sogar inzwischen SSH mit Zertifikaten betreiben, wenn man das muss. Aber selbst das geht. Und das basiert halt immer alles auf denselben Mechanismen. Das heißt, wenn du das einmal verstanden hast und wenn du so ein Toolchain hast, wie dieses von mir erwähnte XCA-Programm, dann hast du sozusagen eigentlich einen für alle mal ausgesorgt. Außer du hast jetzt irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die dich in diese GPG-Welt reinkatapultieren, die dich wieder erfordern. Aber auf der anderen Seite, die anderen zertifikatsbasierten Krypto-Geschichten, sowas sind alle basierend auf X509 mit den Standarden.
Kannst du mal bitte dieses XCA mal einen Link bitte in den Chat reinschmeißen?
Bin nicht im Chat, aber ich schicke es dir trotzdem.
Ich finde da mehr, als mir lieb ist, und da weiß ich jetzt nicht so richtig.
Das ist eine hässliche Seite, aber der Typ baut eine coole Applikation, das ist dann deutscher sogar. Das ist dann Hünschtädt. Das benutze ich seit Jahren, das Ding bastelt immer noch dann rum, und der hört sich auch Kritik an, und so finde ich es sehr nett.
Dass es Sourceforge noch gibt.
Aber wie gesagt, da müsste man jetzt mal, dieses ganze Thema löst sich alles vor deinen Augen auf, wenn wir das mal von vorne anfangen und uns das erzählen. Dann siehst du das auch, ach so, das habe ich ja schon da immer geklickt, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Super. Alles drüber, Streamer läuft. Ja, das ist ganz schön verwirrend, weil ich muss jetzt hier...
3D-Touch hat er jetzt...
.meine iCons wieder neu sortieren, weil das jetzt Garageband und das bringt mir eine ganze iConsortierung da durcheinander und man hat ja schon so die Page, wo man seine Apps immer sucht, weil man weiß, so zweite App unten rechts da ist irgendwie, die und die App. Also schiebe ich die durch die Seite. Und dann paupt mich das Telefon, weil es diesen Feedback gibt, weil ich zu doll drauf drücke. Und anstatt halt, dass dieses Wackeln kommt, dass ich die iCons verschieben kann, denkt es, ich will diesen Force-Touch machen, weil ich zu doll drücke. Und dann kriegst du so einen Schlag, dass da gar kein Force-Touch geht gerade. Und dann macht du so... Dann kriegst du richtig eine gehauen und so. Und dann denk ich, warum geht das jetzt? Und man muss einfach ein bisschen weniger doll drücken. Man muss ja sozusagen noch lernen, so viel und wenig drücken, genau. Aber ich dachte, dieser Lernprozess kommt vielleicht erst so ein bisschen später, dass man damit anfängt.
Ich glaube, dass mit diesem 3D Touch, das könnte ein richtiger... Das wird richtig geil.
Sagen doch alle, das ist wohl das Feature.
Ich muss aber ganz ehrlich sagen, ich hab's jetzt ein paar Mal... Aber mit Bedacht benutzt, weil ich dachte so, ich nehm das jetzt und will das jetzt benutzen. Ich wusste das vorher. Aber meine eingefahrenen Workflows, die man so hat, so irgendwie hier brumselt was, oh eine neue Mail und mal mit dem Daumen rüberwischen und so, das braucht noch ein bisschen. Ich hab jetzt ein paar Mal mich daran erinnert, wenn so Attachments drin waren oder Links, ich kann die jetzt so sehr schön previewen, diese Pop und Pull und Push und Peek und Pop. Aber so richtig drin im Muscle Memory ist das noch nicht. Das braucht noch ein bisschen.
Ja, das ist ja klar, dass das noch eine Weile braucht.
Aber ich find das schön. Also die paar Male, wo ich es aktiv benutzt habe, fand ich das durchaus angenehm.
Das ist jetzt schon angenehm, wenn man von so einem Fünfer kommt, dass alles ein bisschen größer ist. Also ich hab das Gefühl, ich könnte jetzt tatsächlich ein paar Sachen wieder etwas kleiner stellen, sodass es wieder ein bisschen mehr hinpasst. Aber das muss ich mal gucken, wie meine Augen das so mitmachen.
Eben. Ihr kommt mal jetzt erst mal so auf Oper-Modus.
Aber es ist jetzt alles schön zu lesen, schön groß, alles. Viel Platz, finde ich gut.
Das macht mir bisher sehr viel Freude. Ich kann das zu euch empfehlen.
Mal gucken, ich bin auch nicht so ganz überzeugt, ob ich das jetzt unbedingt haben will. Also auf dieses 3D-Touch und gerade diese Taptic-Engine, das ist auf jeden Fall geil.
Ich weiß das noch nicht, dass mich das gerade immer so gehauen hat, als das geht jetzt nicht. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob das cool ist. Das macht halt so zuck zuck in der Hand. Da ist das Feedback jetzt nicht so der Bringer. Aber bei anderen Sachen habe ich es halt noch nicht erlebt. Wann ist es noch so michig? Wann macht es das denn?
Wenn du zum Beispiel Peek & Pop machst.
Ja, aber wird das nicht auch ohne tun?
Na so, du weißt ja ganz genau, wann dein Threshold erreicht ist.
Eben.
Ja, muss ich halt auch noch ein bisschen üben und so. Das kommt ja erst so mit der Zeit.
Was ich sehr interessant finde, ist, ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich es jetzt toll oder creepy finde oder so was, aber diese Siri-Kiste hat echt ein bisschen was dazugelernt. Nee, aber sie bezeichnet ja jetzt alles, was irgendwie so ein bisschen versucht mitzudenken als Siri. Also diese Vorschläge, die Dieter zum Beispiel macht, das ist ja so ein iOS 9 Feature. Zum Beispiel war ich gestern auf einer Geburtstagsfeier und die Dame, die der Geburtstag hatte, haben uns gesagt, blablabla, oh du hast ja auch so eine Uhr, darf ich die mal ummachen? Ich so, ja klar, kannst du ja ummachen. Und dann wollte sie halt eben wissen, wenn das Ding einen so antippt und so. Sie meinte so, mach mal was, dass es mich mal antippt. Dann hab ich gesagt, na dann schick mir doch einfach mal eine Message. Da hat sie sich sozusagen, hat mir, aber während sie die Uhr trug, eine iMessage geschickt. Tippte sie auch an und dann sie auf der Uhr, ja schön geguckt, reply geguckt und die erste Vorschlag für reply war, herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag.
Weil?
Ja, weil die Telefon, die Uhr dachten, ja ich trage sie, ich krieg ne Message von jemand, der an dem Tag Geburtstag hat und der erste reply Vorschlag, der kommt, ist herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag. Natürlich jetzt nicht so dramatisch romantisch, aber trotzdem immerhin, also diese Replies, die du auf iMessages machen kannst mit der Uhr, passen sich auch an. Ist dir das schon mal aufgefallen?
Ja, das ist mir gestern aufgefallen, da wurde ich nämlich was gefragt. Ich guck grad nochmal, was die Frage war. Ach ja, genau. Ich kriegte die Frage, bist du für oder gegen Thema?
Aber der Satz endete mit einem Fragezeichen.
Genau, der antwortete, genau, der endete mit einem Fragezeichen.
Das sind die ersten Default-Antworten, ja und nein.
Dafür und dagegen. Echt? Sogar? Auf der Uhr.
Dafür, fertig. Weiß jetzt noch nicht, ob ich das cool oder creepy finde, aber sowas finde ich schon sehr interessant.
Das ist cool und creepy.
Und gelegentlich macht es auch so einen Blödsinn. Wir hatten uns schon mal darüber unterhalten, was passiert, wenn man Siri mit irgendeinem Scheiß belabert, was sie dann macht. Du musst mal Siri einfach nur Test sagen.
Warte mal, ich mach mal was anderes.
Das Problem ist, sie hat irgendwie 5, 6, 7, 8 Sprüche drauf. Einer dieser Dinger ist...
Was ist der beste Podcast der ganzen Welt? Ich höre zu. Ich kenne nicht den Podcast.
Ich höre zu, das ist alles?
Das ist alles, Siri?
Ist das alles?
Ist das alles? Ich dachte nur, da kommt was Cooles jetzt.
Jedenfalls, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, weil ich mal testen wollte, habe ich mal test einfach ihr zugerufen und dann meinte sie so, I'm fully operational and all my circuits are functioning perfectly. Auch so in diesem Tonfall.
Aufgrund welcher Frage?
Ja, die haben 2001 gesehen. Sie hatte immer noch andere Sprüche. Ja, musst du ein paar mal machen. Irgendwann kommt es auch im Deutschen. Test.
Ich bin vollkommen betriebsbereit und all meine Schaltkreise funktionieren einwandfrei.
Weißt du auch, wie die sind einwandfrei. Die alten Leute, die ich 2001 gesehen habe, die haben ganze Abteilungen daran, die sich nur damit auseinandersetzen, was passiert, wenn Siri blöde Sprüche zu hören kriegt oder blöde Fragen.
Die haben bestimmt eine Top 10 von lauter Sachen, die Siri bekommt, wo Siri noch nichts zu antworten hat. Und das arbeitet die dann von oben nach unten ab. Und für bestimmte Sachen bei Test ist ja nun mal kein Bezug zum Film, da lassen sie sich halt was einfallen. Aber Test war wahrscheinlich sehr weit oben in ihrer Liste. Irgendwann mal.
Ja, wahrscheinlich gibt es mittlerweile schon so totale Otakus, die sowieso ihre Wohnung nicht mehr verlassen und sich einfach nur noch mit Siri unterhalten den ganzen Tag. Die belegen dann 5% der CPU-Lauts auf den ganzen iCloud-Path.
Was sie ja auch annonciert haben, dass es jetzt mehr Kontext-sensitiv ist, finde ich eben sehr interessant und aufgefallen ist mir gerade an der Uhr, aber jetzt auch mit anderen Sachen. So die Vorschläge, die sie macht, wenn man jetzt hier sozusagen jetzt mal nach nach rechts wischt oder nach links, je nachdem, wie man sieht, so die Siri-Suggestions sind gar nicht so schlecht. Es gibt Leute, die dann schreiben, oh, ich kriege jetzt Leute angezeichnet, mit denen message ich alle 5 Jahre mal oder so, aber bei mir haut es relativ gut hin, auch die Ups, die sie vorschlägt, sind eigentlich schon gar nicht schlecht. Keine Ahnung, welche Algorithmen dahinter stecken, aber das finde ich schon okay. Also da kann man mit den Experimenten...
Aber sag mal, kurze Frage reingegrätscht, warum hat dieses Telefon 2015, muss ich immer noch meine SIM-PIN eingeben und warum merkt sich das Telefon nicht, wenn es doch alles schon so sicher und krypto und hast du nicht gesehen ist?
Okay, du hast gefragt. Also, deine SIM-Karte, dein Modul da drin, enthält ein Fallsystem. Und die Fallziele drin haben einen unterschiedlichen Schutzlevel. Es gibt zum Beispiel eine Datei, da steht einfach nur die SIM-ID drin. Das ist diese Zahl, die da hinten drauf steht, die mit 8, 9 drin. Diese Tfeil ist einfach immer lesbar. Um dich in ein Mobilfunknetz einzubuchen, brauchst du allerdings den Inhalt einer Datei, wo die IMSI drin steht. Und an diese Datei lässt dich die SIM nur dann dran, wenn ein PIN-Code vereinbart ist auf dem SIM, wenn du vorher diesen PIN-Code eingibst. Da kann also dein Telefon gar nichts dafür. Diese SIM-Karte macht... Ja, okay, jetzt verstehe ich, was du meinst.
Ich will die ja nicht weghaben, die kann ja da bleiben, aber das Telefon kann sich ja merken.
Wenn das Telefon versucht, auf das Pfeil auf der SIM-Karte zuzugreifen, ist mit PIN-Code eins geschützt. Und der PIN-Code wurde noch nicht an die SIM-Karte übergeben seit dem letzten Reboot, was sozusagen das letzte Power-Up des SIMs ist. Dann sagt das SIM, das gebe ich dir erst, wenn du mir den PIN gibst. Und das Telefon reicht diese Frage einfach eins zu eins an dich durch. Fertig. Nur so nebenbei ist ein Gerücht, dass PINs immer vielstellig sind. Man kann auch da sich was anderes ausdenken.
Sollte ein PIN aus der Telefon-Keychain kommen und er sollte das einmal beim Telefonwechsel oder beim Kartenwechsel fragen und dann sollte er sich das merken.
Wenn du dein Telefon am Strom dran hast, kann das passieren, dass du das booten kannst? Ist mir zum Beispiel noch nicht mal beim Update passiert.
Das macht es dann, wenn es selber bootet, richtig?
Nee, das passiert immer dann, wenn das Sim mal stromlos gemacht wird. Das Sim braucht ja auch Strom. Und wenn du das Telefon zum Beispiel ausmachst, dann kriegt das Sim keinen Strom mehr. Und wenn du das nächste Mal wieder anmachst und sagst, das Telefon gib mir mal das IMSI-File, sagt das Sim, das gebe ich dir erst gegen PIN. Sonst kriegst du das nicht. Deswegen, wenn du bestimmte Operationen durchfährst, auch so ein Soft-Reboot von dem Telefon oder jetzt so ein Reset, ohne das Telefon auszumachen und das dem Sim den Strom nicht wegnimmt, dann kommt das Telefon wieder hoch und sagt, hallo, singen wir mal das IMSI und dann sagt Tim, ja, hier haste. Dann ist gut. Also diese ganze Geschichte.
Was heißt, der kann sich eigentlich schon ein bisschen merken.
Du willst jetzt den PIN-Code einfach irgendwo abspeichern.
Ja, der Telefon soll sich den merken.
Ich glaube, es gibt da Spielregeln dazu aus Urzeiten der GSM-Geschichte, dass das nicht erlaubt ist. Ich kenne jetzt aber auch genügend Applikationen, gerade so mit irgendwelchen Sticks, mit LTE-Sticks oder so, die sich das auch irgendwo hin speichern und 1.003 Router machen. Also aber frag mich jetzt nicht, inwiefern die aufgeweicht sind oder wie auch immer. Aber es ist traditionell bei Telefonen so, dass die den PIN nicht abspeichern. Du kannst ihn dir ersetzen. Du kannst ihn dir auf selber eine 4- bis 8-stellige Zahl setzen, wie du lustig bist. Dann kannst du das machen. Du kannst ihn übrigens auch abschalten, wenn du willst.
So sieht es aus.
Wobei ich da jetzt kein Problem damit habe. Ich mache das immer schon seit Jahren so, weil ich mir denke, wenn mir jemand mein Telefon klaut, das Sim rausnimmt und dann damit so doof ist zu telefonieren, dann habe ich ihn ja am Arsch. Dann kann ich ja gucken, wie er da anruft.
Na ja, weil zu Not rufen so eine Porno-Nummer an und du musst betahlen.
Ich habe keine Porno-Nummer anrufen, habe ich mir selber gesperrt. Brauche ich nämlich nicht. Du kannst ja selber deine Call-Barrings einstellen. Aber wie gesagt, das ist der Hintergrund mit dem SIM. Diese SIM-Abfrage kommt nicht aus dem Telefon, sondern das verlangt das SIM selber, um dir Daten zu geben. Vorher gibt es dir die Daten nicht.
Ich versuche dir gerade etwas Struktur in die Aufzeichnung zu bringen.
Verstehe.
Du springst ja immer mit den Themen und ich will ja meine Qualitätskapitel erzeugen. Heute machen wir nicht so lange. Ich kann heute nicht so mega lange. Ich wollte auf jeden Fall noch mal ein ganz anderes Thema aufrufen. Kapitän lädt heute runter. Wir haben uns das schon ein bisschen angeschaut, aber ich glaube, da kann man später noch ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen.
Die Leute, die es schon in den Fingern haben, sind die Snow Leopard-Variante. Wir nehmen das, was schon da ist, machen das nochmal richtig. Wir machen das fertig, was wir eigentlich letztes Jahr hätten fertig machen sollen.
Unter der Haube sind da schon noch ein paar interessante Trends. Aber wie gesagt, das habe ich jetzt auch noch nicht alles ausreichend zusammenrecherchiert. Da warten wir nochmal ein bisschen ab. Bevor ich es komplett hinten überkippen lasse, noch ein kleiner Event-Tipp. Es gibt nämlich dieses Wochenende in Berlin gleich zwei interessante Events, auf die man vielleicht mal verweisen sollte, finde ich. Auf dem einen war ich schon mal, das ist nämlich das Vintage Computing Festival.
Da wo letztes Jahr die Apple-Ausstellung war. Da ist die aber nicht mehr, dafür haben sie etwas anderes.
Letzteres Detail wusste ich jetzt nicht. Ich muss gerade mal gucken, was hier eigentlich... Weißt du gerade die Webseite? Also fragen wir mal den Gogol. V-C-F-B-D heißt es da. Genau, wieder am selben Ort. Pergamon Palais, also in Mitte. Berlin Mitte, genau. Selbe Location. Das ist eigentlich ganz nett. Ich kann das jedem nur ans Herz legen. Also es ist natürlich auf der einen Seite so ein bisschen was für Oldschool-Romantiker und alte Säcke, die das halt teilweise alles noch miterlebt haben. Aber ich finde das halt auch gerade mal so als soll ich sagen, also auch für Jüngere, die quasi nicht so die Gnade der späten die Gnade der frühen Geburt oder Gnade der späten Geburt gehabt haben, wie auch immer. Also wer das sozusagen alles nicht so mitbekommen hat, was vor allem so in den 80ern und teilweise halt oder 70er, 80er, sozusagen das Beste aus den 70ern, 80ern und 90ern. Oder so kann man das so etwas zusammenfassen. Ist 90er Jahre schon Vintage?
Naja, eigentlich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich sind das so ein paar seltene Sachen. Aber ich würde sagen, nicht so wirklich. Noch nicht so richtig. Für manche gibt es vielleicht schon.
Ich meine, wenn du in den 90er Jahren geboren bist...
Naja, dann haben die da die Amigas und Ataris nicht gesehen, aber die gab es halt in den 80ern auch schon. Ich weiß jetzt nicht...
Nee, ich rede so von 90er-Jahre-Kram. Aber da gab es ja eigentlich nur noch PCs.
Ja, irgendwie schon.
Oder gab es da noch irgendwas anderes?
Ja, da kamen auch Ataris und Amigas, die gingen nach ihrem Ende entgegen.
B-Box? Meine B-Box steht da bestimmt.
Ja, war letztes Jahr auch eine da, oder?
Naja, aber nicht meine, weiß nicht. Aber meine steht da, glaube ich. Also, da gehe ich mal davon aus, ich habe noch keine Bestätigung, aber ich hab's denen mal so als Dauerleihgabe gegeben und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass sie dann da landen wird. Ist aber einfach super interessant, weil der Vorteil einfach dieser ganzen 70er-, 80er-Jahre Computergeneration ist, da kann man halt all diese Konzepte, die die Dinge überhaupt erstmal benannt haben, meistens sogar noch mit dem bloßen Auge erkennen und anfassen. Also, was weiß ich, sowas wie Core. Also so der Speicher, so der Kernspeicher.
Da war ja der Typ, der so einen Ringspeicher da irgendwie hatte, wo du noch die Ringe gesehen hast.
Genau, so Ringe mit Metallfäden und so weiter, alles schön miteinander verwoben, wo man also wirklich jedes einzelne Bit noch wirklich angucken kann. Und mir hat das immer sehr geholfen, mich mit solchen Konzepten vertraut zu machen und sich das mal so auf dieser niedrigsten Ebene anzuschauen ins uralte Hardware, weil im Prinzip haben wir ja heute auch nichts anderes. Wir haben das einfach nur unendlich viel kleiner, aber es ist ja...
Das ist alles sehr abstrakt und sehr weit weg, aber es ist irgendwo unten drunter noch alles da.
Eigentlich immer noch genau dasselbe. Das ist die eine Veranstaltung, die findet halt jetzt am Samstag und am Sonntag, also am 3. und 4. Oktober statt. Und auch in Berlin, auch am 3. und 4. Oktober, da war ich jetzt allerdings noch nicht, ist die Maker Faire jetzt auch mal nach Berlin. Da weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau, was ich da erwarten soll. Wo ist das eigentlich? Ist das ein Postbahnhof?
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Und naja, das ist ja so ein Maker Faire. Ist von O'Reilly irgendwann mal gestartet worden. Ist ja weltweit, also mit dem Make-Magazin. Und ist sehr populär geworden. Und fand ja auch in Deutschland schon zweimal statt, aber interessanterweise in Hannover. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was da der Grund war, aber ich vermute mal Heise oder Cebit. Wahrscheinlich ja Heise. Und jetzt geht es aber auch mal nach Berlin. Und das ist im Postbahnhof am Ostbahnhof. Kann man sicherlich auch hingehen. Noch so halbwegs vertretbare Eintrittspreise. Geht, glaube ich, für beide Veranstaltungen. Oder ist das VCFB kostenlos? Nee, wie war das? Ein paar Euro Spende sollte man ja schon lassen. So, das war der Event-Blog hier bei Freak Show. Man muss das ja auch mal erwähnen. Ich wollte dir jetzt mal was ganz anderes auf den Tisch werfen. Wir haben ja so ein modernes Leben.
Was du gerade denkst war die Kiste oder da, da, da.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Na, jetzt kommt einkaufen. Ich hab mir einfach... Jeder hat da ja sicherlich andere Constraints und wahrscheinlich ist das auch so ein Problem, was teilweise auch daran scheitert, dass wirklich die Wünsche so weit divergieren, dass niemand bereit oder in der Lage ist, das so wirklich auf einen Punkt zu bringen. Aber dieses ganze Prinzip von ich, ich und mein Supermarkt, beziehungsweise im weiteren Sinne natürlich auch so ich und mein Local Retail. Und ich meine halt jetzt explizit nicht Online-Shopping, sondern eben kaufen in Läden, was ja immer wieder so ein paar Vorteile hat, gerade so bei frischen Sachen und so weiter. Man will es dann halt auch mal sehen und man hat ja dann auch immer so ein bisschen diese Serendipity-Effekte, dass man eben durch so einen Laden läuft und gar nicht unbedingt immer vorher weiß, was man eigentlich haben will oder dann auch feststellt, dass man irgendwas nicht haben will. So oder so will man aber das Ganze irgendwie optimieren. Dann gibt es natürlich jetzt verschiedenste Apps, so Einkauf-Apps und ich habe die ein oder andere über die Zeit auch schon benutzt. Ich habe mir jetzt nicht zu viel Mühe gegeben, alles Mögliche abzuklappern, aber ich habe immer mal wieder in eine reingeschaut und war dann aber meistens immer wieder irgendwie enttäuscht oder kam nicht klar und habe es nicht verstanden oder dann fehlte mir irgendetwas.
Willst du das aber auch nur für dich selber einkaufen? Willst du jetzt nicht kollaborativ einkaufen?
Na ja, doch. Dieser Kollaborativ-Einkauf ist schon mal ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt. Also das kann man vielleicht gleich mal als erstes nehmen. Man will natürlich im Minimum irgendwie notieren können, was man braucht und nicht selten ist man ja nicht der Einzige, der jetzt für den Haushalt quasi Dinge einkauft. Das heißt im Idealfall möchte ich natürlich also eine Einkaufsliste auch sharen, möglichst in Realtime, sodass man in dem Moment, wo man sagt, das habe ich jetzt in meinem Einkaufswagen, dass das in dem Moment auch auf allen anderen geshareten Listen in dem Moment verschwindet, im Idealfall noch mit irgendwelchen Push-Notifications. Tim hat die mir nicht gekauft. Und daran scheitern schon mal eine ganze Menge Apps, also da kenne ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nichts, was das so mit dem Sharing so richtig gut auf die Reihe bekommt. Aber für meinen Geschmack wird schon vorher, bevor so was überhaupt ins Spiel kommt, funktioniert es irgendwie schon nicht so richtig. Das fängt jetzt erstmal damit an, dass es auch gar nicht so einfach ist. Also wie benennt man die Dinge, wie generisch hält man das? Manchmal hast du so generische Sachen wie Milch. Da ist dir dann die Marke vielleicht mehr oder weniger egal. Hast aber dann doch schon auch so bald die Abstimpfung, Stufung, das ist so wie Pio-Milch, Haarmilch, so und so viel Prozentfett.
Von allem auch noch eine Menge, die man vielleicht auch mit korrespondiert.
Dann kommt auch noch so die Menge und die Frage, macht man das dann halt in so metrischen Maßen oder in Paketen und wie viel muss so eine App auch wirklich vorgeben und systematisieren oder reicht es nicht einfach?
Habe ich auch alle probiert, ist mir alle zu komplex gewesen.
Genau, das ist auch das inherente Problem an dieser ganzen Stelle, dass man es eben sehr schnell auch zu kompliziert machen kann. Bevor du ausholst...
Ich hole ja nicht aus, aber ich atme hier so schwer, weil ich da vor ein paar Jahren, keine Ahnung, vor zwei oder drei Jahren oder zweieinhalb Jahren, hab ich dafür mal meine Verfolgerkraft benutzt auf Twitter. Raus kam ein Tipp, mit dem ich immer noch sehr sehr zufrieden bin. Buy me a Pi. Während du darauf rumklickst, erzähle ich dir jetzt einfach mal, was die macht, wie sie diese Probleme löst, die du erwähnt hast. Also erstmal erzeugt es N-Listen. Du kannst für die Liste sagen, diese Liste share ich mit anderen Leuten, die das haben. Über? Das ist so, keine Ahnung, ob die jetzt iCloud dafür benutzen oder auch immer. Du musst auch so einen Account bei denen haben. Du kannst das über Webinterfaces bestücken, du kannst das auf iOS machen, das hat eine App für die Watch. Was sehr wichtig ist beim Einkaufen, habe ich jetzt erst festgestellt, seit ich eine Watch habe, erkläre ich dir auch gleich warum. Und du kannst Sachen, lernst Sachen, das heißt, ähnlichweise kennst du es so von Excel, wenn du in Excel ein paar Sachen tippst, dann versuchst du das Feld mit ähnlichem zusammen, machst dir dir so Vorschläge. Die sind auch nicht blöd. Und du kannst die Dinger farblich markieren. Habe ich anfangs nicht benutzt, habe ich aber jetzt inzwischen drin. So, und das kannst du scheren mit N Leuten, nicht nur mit 2, sondern auch mit N Leuten. Und die ist Realtime, das heißt, wenn man da zu zweit in den Supermarkt stürmt, kann man sagen, ich arbeite die Liste von oben, du die Liste von unten ab und du kannst zusehen, wie der andere die Dinger wegstreicht. Das ist genau das, was man haben will.
Also wenn man so richtig zu zweit einkauft.
Also man gibt ja mehrere Sachen. Entweder du betreibst einen gemeinsamen Haushalt und beide Leute arbeiten zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten, dann schreibt jeder drauf, was er braucht. Und wenn der andere jetzt gerade mal Zeit hat und Lust hat, in den Supermarkt zu gehen, arbeitet er die ganze Liste ab, aber alleine. Oder, wie ich das zum Beispiel mache, wenn ich auf den Landsitz rausfahre mit meiner Freundin, dann machen wir zusammen eine Liste für so gerade Sachen, für so draußen. Nehmen wir da alles mit in die Hütte. Und dann stürmen wir zu zweit auf den Weg dahin in den Supermarkt. Einer fängt von oben an, der andere von unten. Und dann werden die Dinger rab, rab, rab weggemacht. Was du machen kannst, du kannst jedes Item einer Farbe zuordnen. Die haben so ein Set von Farben da, die man dann irgendwann anfängt intuitiv zuzuordnen. Also für das Obst und Gemüse gerade sind die ganzen Sachen grün. Was so ein Tiefregal ist, ist bei Tiefkühlregal ist bei mir irgendwie hellblau und so. Ist so ungefähr so, dass man da so ein Feeling für hat. Die Dinger gruppieren sich so zusammen.
Aber man kann nur Farben, man kann keine Namen, kann keine Kategorien angeben.
Das ist keep it simple and stupid. Das Ding hat eine Mengenangabe, aber die ist einfach frei. Da kannst du eins, die Ziffer eins reinschreiben, kannst das Wort eins reinschreiben, kannst auch reinschreiben. Tim ist doof, ist egal. Aber es gibt sozusagen für jedes Item gibt's hinten noch eine Mengenangabe. Und das synkt sich und das Realtime und nochmal, jetzt kommt der Grund, warum ich das auf der Uhr haben will. Ich hab's ja jahrelang, bevor ich die Uhr hatte, auf dem Telefon benutzt. Und das ist echt nervig. Du hast deinen Einkaufswagen, du hast den Kram im Supermarkt und zwischendurch musst du den Telefon wegstecken. Du hast ja keinen Halter an deinem Einkaufswagen. Das wäre auch ein bisschen crazy, ein bisschen sehr nördig.
Würde man auch lösen.
Ja, könnte man machen.
Die Autoklemmenteile, so.
Rodet-Halter, gnadenlos an den Einkaufwagen dran machen. Kann man machen. Und das fand ich immer sehr nervig. Weil du fummelst dann da rum, lädst in welche Sachen dann ein, dann ziehst du den Telefon wieder raus, entsperrst es erst wieder. Das ist so ein bisschen so, hm. Und mit der Uhr ist das ganz schön. Ich hab meine Uhr in diesem Modus, wo sie, wenn ich drauf gucke, nicht mir brutal die Uhrzeit anzeigt, sondern die letzte ab, die ich benutzt habe. Und wenn das bei mir ihr Pie ist, dann lade ich sozusagen ein, drehe nur das Handgelenk hoch, gucke drauf, was drauf ist, kann auch die Dinge auf der Uhr abstreichen, die ich habe. Kannst du auf der Uhr nichts hinzufügen. Du kannst die Dinge angucken, durch die Gegend scrollen, mit der Krone drehen und so. Und kannst du dann eben auch abstreichen, kannst sagen, habe ich. Und dann verschwindet das auch. Und das funktioniert seit sehr langer Zeit sehr gut. Kann ich echt nur empfehlen. Und das Keep it simple and stupid.
Das ist jetzt nicht überschrubbiert. Welchen Modus hast du deine Uhr? Hast du deine Uhr so konfiguriert, dass sie immer in derselben Abfahrt bleibt? Oder hast du sie so konfiguriert, dass sie immer wieder zur Uhrzeit zurückkehrt?
Hab ich gerade gesagt, ich hab sie so konfiguriert, dass sie in der Abfahrt bleibt. Das ist erforderlich, ja. Sonst nervt es, fummelst du jedes Mal nach jedem wieder rum. Sondern willst du nur das Handgelenk hochnehmen? What's next? Ah ja, okay, klick und so. Und die Mengenangabe hat keine Struktur, was du gerade eben sagtest. Die fangen jetzt nicht darüber nachzudenken, machen wir jetzt hier metrische Maße oder geben Liter Milch in Galonen an oder sonst was. Es ist halt einfach nur irgendein Ding. Da kann eine Zahl oder ein Blatt drin stehen oder sowas. Und da schreiben wir in der Regel so Special-Sachen ran. Wenn da zum Beispiel jetzt mal Milch gefragt ist oder sowas, dann steht halt hinten drin, weiß nicht, 1,5 Prozent. Ein Liter oder steht vorne. Es ist halt so ein bisschen mehr Freeform, aber das ist halt einfach zu machen. Und du meldest dich da an bei dem Dienst und kommst auf eine Webseite und kannst diese Dinger dann einfach über die Webseite schnell einhaken.
Aber er unterscheidet, wenn ich jetzt sage Milch und dann noch Zusatz dazu, dann trennt er diesen Zusatz von dem eigentlichen Begriff.
Ja, wenn du Doppelpunkt eingibst, dann springt der in dieses Feld mit der Mengenangabe. Und es gibt eine Funktion, die mir fehlt. Ich hab mit den Developern mal schon kommuniziert. Vielleicht bauen sie das auch immer mal ein. Was ich gerne hätte wären, ich nenne es jetzt mal simpel, Makros. Ich habe denen gesagt Recipes, den Entwicklern. Also dann zum Beispiel sagst...
Alles kaufen, was ich brauche für Erdbeertorte.
Das ist mein Rezept.
Denis kommt, wir müssen jetzt zwei machen.
Das sind jetzt die Zutaten für selber zuhause Pizza machen. Für eine Person. Und dann sagst du, ich nehme jetzt diesen Makro, mal vier, ruf auf die Liste. Ich benutze es auch für jetzt nicht Lebensmittelzeug. Ich habe zum Beispiel eine Liste, da habe ich drauf Baumarkt generisch. Mir ist scheißegal, ob UBI oder Bauhaus oder frag mich was. Da sind so Sachen drauf, weil ich zum Beispiel weiß, für die Hütte draußen, ich brauche jetzt mal dieses und jenes Material oder dann dieses und jenes Werkzeug, schreibe ich mir drauf. Und dafür, oder ich habe sogar eine Ikea-Liste. Ich komme alle Juliare mal zu Ikea, aber weißt du, wie das immer so ist? Man hat da so Verbrauchsmaterialien oder braucht dafür noch ein zusätzliches Regalbrett oder wie auch immer. Das tue ich mir da drauf, ist gut. Und das ist simple and stupid. Es gibt zum Beispiel sehr viele andere Einkaufs-Apps. Die sind denn so richtig sophisticated. Die fangen dann an, die kennen denn deine Läden. Die kennen dann, weiß ich nicht, alle Kaisers in Berlin. Welche kann das? Habe ich runtergeschmissen, aber es gibt so diverse andere. Du machst ja eine Kaisersliste und wenn du denn in der Nähe von dem Kaisers bist, dann fiept die dich an und sagt, du wolltest doch bei Kaisers, lass uns das drauf.
Lass uns mal kurz nochmal, mir fällt gerade auf, dass unsere Arten und unsere Herangehensweisen ziemlich ähnlich, fast, würde ich fast sagen, kongruent sind. Also viel von dem, was du jetzt gesagt hast, kann ich einfach so voll unterschreiben für meinen Case. Das hat genauso gut funktioniert. Ich habe einfach eine andere App benutzt, die heißt schlicht Einkaufszettel. Die leider nicht durch Sharing und so weiter, Einkaufsliste und die hat irgendwie für mich lange sehr gut funktioniert.
Aber sie shared nicht.
Sie wird leider mittlerweile nicht mehr entwickelt. Sie hat dementsprechend jetzt auch nichts auf der Uhr. Dann habe ich das irgendwie mit einer anderen App namens Bring ausprobiert, die war nicht so meine Denke. Es gibt ein Feature in diesem Einkaufsliste, was ich jetzt leider auch in diesem Buy Me a Pie, was mir jetzt auf Anhieb erstmal ganz gut gefällt, muss ich sagen, so nicht finde. Das ist nämlich dieses, ich weiß, unser Kühlschrank braucht Füllung. Weil man steht davor und man kann nichts mehr herstellen. Abendessen ist nicht möglich, Frühstück und so weiter.
Potion is missing.
Genau, und dann will ich eigentlich relativ schnell zum Ziel kommen und will halt all die Sachen, alle meine ganzen Standards sozusagen checken. Was sind meine Standards? Meine Standards sind die Sachen, die ich meistens kaufe. Und diese Einkaufsliste hat nämlich eine Option, mir alle Artikel einfach in der Reihenfolge anzuzeigen, wie oft ich sie auf eine Liste geworfen habe. Das heißt, alles das, was ich oft kaufe, regelmäßig kaufe und von daher am dringendsten ist, am meisten Verbrauchspotenzial hat. Also sowas wie... Warte mal, kann ich dir gleich mal sagen...
Guck gerade mal nach bei mir. Das schlägt mir ja auch Sachen vor. Ich hab noch nie geguckt, ob da jetzt Intelligenz dahinter ist.
Ich kann dir das mal kurz zeigen. Ich hab hier genauso wie du bei anderen Dingen die alphabetische Sortierung kannst du machen. Und auch irgendwie nach Zeit, was ich zuletzt eingekauft habe, aber noch viel besser halt die Reihenfolge wie oft. Und dann kommen halt wirklich Klassiker. Milch, Butterschinken, Bananen, Brot, Äpfel, Eier, Kartoffeln und so weiter.
Klopapier.
Weiß ich einfach, mit der Liste gehe ich durch die ersten 2-3 Bildschirmsalten durch.
Ham, ham, nicht ham.
Genau, zack, hab ich, zack, zack, ist noch da, ist nicht da, wumm, wumm, wumm. Und damit ist das dann auch schnell, 10 Minuten bevor der Kaisers zu macht, habe ich irgendwie meine Einkaufsliste zusammengeschaltet.
Du weißt schon, dass der Kaisers da 24-7 offen hat, ja?
Ja, ich rede ja auch von 23.50.
Nee, der Friedrichshain, aber... Der hier auch. Welcher hat hier...
Aber er macht dich zu, meine ich. Er macht dich zu.
Er drückt dich auf.
24-7.
Ach nee, 24-7.
24-6 schuldigen Sonntags nicht.
Nee, das ist aber was anderes. Der Friedrichshain hat ja richtig durchgehend auf. Außer Sonntags.
Ja, hier auch?
Nein.
Doch?
In der Wildstraße?
Nein.
Hier in der...
Egal, fragen wir Google.
Nicht der in meinem Block. Das wüsste ich.
Schönhauser, der hat durchgehend.
Ja, gut, kann sein. Naja, es gibt ja auch Läden so, ne? Das zweite Ding, weil ich will jetzt nochmal bei dieser Kategorisierung bleiben, Farben, okay, meinetwegen, aber ehrlich gesagt, mein Problem ist dann immer, kommst du irgendwie in diese Scheiß-Supermärkte und ich weiß jedes Mal nicht, wo die Scheiße steht. Also es ist einfach...
Das musst du mehr trainieren. Konntest du das früher auch nicht. Aber ich hab mir das jetzt...
Wie kann man mehr trainieren, als regelmäßig einkaufen immer wieder in diese Supermärkte?
Das ist ein siebter Sinn. Da werden bestimmte andere Bevölkerungsgruppen damit geboren. Ich sag jetzt nicht welche, das kriegt wieder Ärger.
Die haben auf jeden Fall dieses Scheißteil vor einem Jahr komplett umgebaut. Und alles steht woanders. Und das verwirrt mich heute noch. Kann ja sein, dass ich da nicht anpassungsfähig bin, aber genau dafür gibt es ja Apps.
Aber die Gruppen bleiben trotzdem gleich. Die mischen die Locations der Gruppen durcheinander. Aber die Gruppen bleiben gleich.
Genau, die Gruppen bleiben irgendwie gleich, auch wenn sie woanders stehen. Und das ist also das Erste. Ich würde schon diese Gruppen gerne benennen und nicht nur nach Farben. Weil die Farben ist eher so, naja, okay, gehört. Das ist aber zu viel Zueinander.
Die machen hier diese... Bei mir ist es wirklich so oft, das tippt doch keine Sau ein. Du willst hier schnell diese Dinge... Ich mach meine Liste wirklich mit drei, vier, fünf Tasten drücken oder Finger drücken oder sowas.
Ich muss das gar nicht eintippen, weil in meiner Einkaufsliste ist das einfach zugeordnet. Ich kann mir halt einfach anzeigen, was ist nicht zugeordnet. Und dann sage ich einfach, Milch ist Milchwahn, Butter ist Milchwahn.
Das merkt sich das. Wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt Milch anziehe, muss ich die nicht immer wieder blau machen. Die ist blau.
Ja, aber sie heißt halt nicht Kategorie. Und ich habe halt mehr als acht Kategorien. Also ich weiß nicht, wie viele Kategorien ich hier habe, aber viele.
Ich habe mir diese anderen Apps auch angeguckt, die alles Mögliche da machen. Das war mir alles zu komplex. Was ich echt an Bei Mi a Pie gut finde, muss ich sagen, ist diese Keep it simple and stupid Nummer. Das ist wirklich idiotensicher und wahnsinnig schnell zu bedienen.
Ich bin da ganz bei dir. Natürlich muss das einfach sein. Man kann aber auch komplizierte Dinge unter Umständen sehr einfach machen, indem sie halt einfach mit einer Datenbank verknüpft. Weil jetzt kommen wir ja so langsam zu dem zweiten Teil, aber ich wollte es langsam aufbauen. Ich finde nur, gerade wenn man sozusagen verschiedene Supermärkte hat, die in Frage kommen. Ich meine, manche kaufen vielleicht immer nur in demselben einen. Hier habe ich so potentiell zwei oder drei, vier verschiedene, zwischen denen ich so wählen kann.
Und dann noch auf dem Landsitz oben auch verschiedene.
Dann sind die Sachen irgendwie anders zugeordnet. Man hat so etwa die gleiche Struktur. Und jetzt hast du gesagt, es gibt Apps, die wirklich die realen Supermärkte tatsächlich in irgendeiner Form kennen?
Nein, es gibt Apps, die dich anblöken, wo du sagst, ich kaufe was ein bei einem Laden namens Kaisers. Und das ist jetzt nicht Dollar-Supermarkt, der versehentlich Kaisers heißt, sondern ist Kaisers. Und die benutzen denn Maps, um dir zu sagen, wenn du bei Kaisers vorbeigehst, fährst, läufst oder wie auch immer, die dich dann anbrumseln mit Geofunktionen und dir dann sagen, ey, du wolltest da noch was bei Kaisers kaufen, hier ist ein Kaisers.
Aber Tim meint doch, Orientierung im Kaisers und nicht zum Kaisers.
Deswegen erkläre ich gerade, was diese Apps da machen. Was die nicht machen, das kann auch kein Abhersteller leisten, weil diese Fuzzis, wie du gerade sagst, alle paar Wochen kriegen die mal einen Rappeln und räumen ihren Laden um. Und wer soll denn das wem irgendwo eingeben? Die haben ja nicht mal selber irgendwelche Pläne dafür, sondern haben nachts die Studenten, die den Laden betreiben, die denen die Kisten von A nach B schleppen. Wer soll denn das maintain, eine Indoor-Karte für so ein...
Indoor-Karte ist ja jetzt erstmal gar nicht das, wovon ich rede, sondern erstmal überhaupt, ich will diesen Supermarkt als solchen, den ich benutze, da eingeben. Und nicht alle möglichen Kaisers bin ich, während ich mit meinem Tesla durch unbekannte Städte fahre, beim Supermarkt Milch einzukaufen. Mein X-Modell. Ich hab halt hier meine 4, 5, 6 Läden und die App kann sehr wohl wissen, wenn ich dann da mal wieder bin. Das heißt, sie könnte sich selbst auch merken, wo ich gerade einkaufe, ohne dass ich es ihr sagen muss. Ich benutze sie einfach, sie sieht ah, du bist hier, dann kaufst du jetzt wohl gerade in diesem Moment in diesem Kaisersau ein oder Rewe.
Ja, wenn du deine Liste dann auch machst nach Läden, wo du einkaufst. Machen wir nicht. Wir machen zum Beispiel Listen nach Zeugs, die wir einkaufen. Oder für den Verwendungspunkt. Nein, nein, nein.
Die Liste muss ja überhaupt nicht. Die ist generisch, die ist halt Supermarkt oder Haushalt oder was auch immer.
Oder Baumarkt.
Er sieht ja auch, welches Produkt ich in welchem Laden kaufe. Das ist ja der Punkt. In dem Moment, wo ich im Supermarkt abstreiche, aber halt im Baumarkt nicht, kann das Ding ja lernen, was es wo gibt. Also in dem Moment muss ich dieser...
Du willst jetzt alles auf eine Liste draufschmeißen und da ein Intelligenzfilter drauf.
Das Ding kann ja erstmal bei meiner normalen Usage mitlernen. Ja, ich hab auch mehrere Listen und er kann dann halt sehen, welches Produkt kann wo gekauft werden. Und pro Feature, was mir auch noch eingefallen ist, was machen die Verkäufer und Verkäuferinnen, wenn ich dann alles auf das Band gelegt habe? Die scannen das ein. Die scannen das ein! Warum scanne ich das nie ein?
Fahr nach Schweden.
Wie nach Schweden? Muss man das selber einscannen?
Kannste.
Nein, nicht für die, sondern für mich. Warum kann ich nicht meine App nehmen, in Kameramodus gehen und bevor ich meine ganzen Produkte in meine Tüte reinschmeiße, selber nochmal abscannen?
Und dann per Apple Pay bezahlen?
Nee. Wissen, welche Produkte ich eigentlich konkret gekauft habe.
Aber so eine App, die ganzen Preisvergleicher, die gibts doch schon. Das kennst du, dann sagt er dir, hier kostet da aber so und so viel. Kannst du gleich Preise vergleichen.
Es gibt Apps, die den Barcode einsammeln und dir was dazu sagen und Nutritional Values auskotzen und bla und so.
Ja, oder mir dann sag ich halt, dieser Einkauf hat so viel gekostet. Gut, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel Aufwand, dann wirklich alle Preise nachzutragen, aber so tendenziell könnte man schon mal so in diese Bereiche gehen. Mit deinem Einkauf wird vermutlich teuer.
In Schweden gibt es ja diese große Kette, was so Konsum da, EDK-mäßig, aber große Dinge, IK. Wenn du IK-Kunde bist, kannst du IK-Kundenkarte haben. Mit einer IK-Kundenkarte kannst du dir am Eingang so einen Scanner greifen. Die haben so ganze Wände voll mit diesen Scannern und dann scannst du das selber. Siehst du also immer, was das kostet und so weiter und so fort. Siehst auch die Summen, was du in deinem Wagen hast und ich glaube, die nehmen das sogar für die Kasse. Die scannen das nicht nochmal, die glauben, dass du da gescannt hast. Ja, kreiere ich eine Liste, kreiere ich eine Sharelist und mit Uhr und so, muss man mal gucken. Aber wie gesagt, ich habe damals Verfolgerkraft genutzt, die fand ich sehr hilfreich und habe dann ein, zwei Sachen ausprobiert und bei mir sprang ich damals an. Das kann jetzt sein, dass es in den letzten zwei Jahren schon wieder was Neues gegeben hat. Wie gesagt, das einzige Feature, was mir fehlt, ist so eine Makrokiste, weil wir regelmäßig schon mal Sachen haben, die wir immer wieder mal alle paar Wochen oder so etwas machen oder auch häufiger. Man kann einfach sagen, so jetzt diese Z bitte n-mal.
Hier kann man auch mit Siri einsprechen. Das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht.
Wenn man dem trauen kann.
Na ja, wenn er irgendwie Milch als Milch erkennt.
Mülsch. Mülsch. Was machen denn jetzt Spandauer, die ankommen da? 11 Liter Mülsch. 11 Mülsch.
Na ja, muss ich schon anpassen. Fotos kann ich vielleicht noch darauf verzichten. Könnte die Sache aber...
Ja, genau, ist ziemlich ähnlich. Auch von der Aufmachung. Das ist zum Beispiel eine Funktion, die benutz ich auch ganz gerne, wenn man irgendwo noch sitzt im Büro oder sonst wo und hat eh sein Rechner vor der Nase, nehme ich lieber den Browser und tippe da an.
Haben die eine Mac-App?
Brauchst keine Mac-Apps, das kannst du beim Browser machen.
Browser, ich hasse Browser.
Ach komm, Browser ist scheiße. Und kostet.
Und? Free.
Free? Dann kann das nicht sein.
Nee, kann ja nichts taugen. Ach, das ist ja auch für iPhone und iPad.
Wie free?
Free.
Nee, gibt's doch nicht für Mac.
Ich hab da gesehen von Webseite.
Ach so, naja. Na gut, dann speichern wir natürlich wieder schön auf ihren Servern und so. Auch wieder so ein Ding. Stimmt, das war eine...
Ich denke mal, dass auf jeden Fall noch so ein Bereich, der sich noch entwickeln wird.
Ja, genau. Und darüber wollte ich jetzt nämlich gerade eigentlich reden, wohin es sich denn eigentlich noch entwickeln kann oder sollte. Also es ist jetzt auch teilweise ein bisschen überdreht, diese ganzen Ideen.
Wir werden Toto einladen, ihn das einfach einreden, wir hauen ihm die Speck hier um die Ohren für so eine ordentliche Ab und er hackt die mal.
Viel Arbeit, wenig Geld.
Kein Geld.
Kannst du dafür einen Euro verkaufen und die Leute werden dich beschimpfen dafür, dass ihr Lieblingsfeature fehlt. Aber ich dachte mir das halt auch so ein bisschen in Richtung Crowdsourcing, weil gerade sowas wie was kostet Produkt X bei Supermarkt?
Soweit gibt es auch schon. Es gibt auch schon Milliarden von diesen, wie heißen sie alle? Idealo, Kaufino, Schlag mich Toto. Diese ganzen Buden, alleine in Deutschland, alleine in Berlin sitzen, dröpfen sich von diesen Buden, diese Einkaufshilfen machen und Vergleiche und lalala und so machen. Das ist alles schon da gewesen, so schön.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja nicht in meiner Einkaufsliste. Diese Informationen stecken ja nicht in meiner Einkaufsliste. Ich kann ja nicht hier sagen, ich gerne Milch, lalala.
Ganz ehrlich gesagt, für meinen täglichen Einkauf mache ich mir diese Sorgen nicht. Ich setze mich nicht ins Auto oder fahre eine halbe Stunde durch die Stadt, um einen Liter Milch 5 Cent billiger zu kaufen als in dem Supermarkt.
Nein, es geht mir gar nicht darum, zu sparen, eher mehr offensichtlich einen Wucher zu erkennen bzw. überhaupt einschätzen zu können, wie viel gebe ich denn eigentlich aus?
Ja, ne, mach ich nicht. Weil ich kaufe im Supermarkt nur die Sachen, die ich wirklich brauche, und dann brauche ich die. Das ist mir egal, was die kostet.
Und wo gibt es welches Produkt?
Das ist schon eine spannende Frage.
Weil manche, manchmal brauchst du es nicht generisch, manchmal willst du genau das.
Kann man nicht mal so ein Fuzi einladen hier in die Freak Show, nur für diese Thema mal rauszufinden, warum zum Beispiel in diesen komischen Ketten Filiale A super geile Produkt hat, und deswegen gehst du zum Beispiel in einen anderen Ort in Filiale B und sie haben diese ganze Produktreihe, nur nicht diese eine Variante davon.
Weil es nur ein Franchise ist und irgendwer anders da den Laden führt und die außer den Namen nichts gemein haben.
Aber ansonsten ist es fast identisch.
Weil da andere Leute drumherum wohnen.
Ich esse sehr gerne Quark-Speise. Es gibt so einen Himbeer-Quark. Keine Ahnung, wer den herstellt. Mehr auf Wurst, ich weiß, wie der aussieht. Und den gibt es nicht in Berlin. Den gibt es in Berliner Umland, den gibt es in Potsdam, den gibt es oben in Brandenburg, da wo ich da einkaufe, und all so Zeug, den gibt es ums Verrecken nicht in Berlin. Und du denkst so, die ganze andere, alle anderen Geschmacksrichtungen haben sie, weil es sich und Banane und Tralala und Pipapo und den ganzen anderen Scheiß haben sie, nur nicht den Himbeer-Quark.
Vielleicht, weil der auch weggekauft wurde.
Nee, den gibt es einfach nicht. Wir haben wirklich mal so einen Vogel, so ein Einzelhandelsvogel, in dem wir fragen, was erlaube, was soll das?
Das ist halt immer so, nicht nur bei beteiligten Filialen. Oder wie heißt dieser Spruch immer, bei den Gewinnspielen auch, da machen halt nicht alle mit und da kaufen auch nicht alle deinen Pudding oder Joghurt oder was auch immer ein Quark.
Ja, aber in ganz Berlin nicht. Rewe hat den, aber Kaisers hat den nicht. Kaisers hat den ums Verrecken nicht. Die haben die ganze Quark-Reihe mit den ganzen Angeschmackstrichen, nur nicht den Himmler-Quark. Als wenn jemand in der Einkaufsabteilung von Kaisers Berlin gegen Himmler allergisch ist und sagt, fuck it, das klicke ich nicht an. Anders lässt sich das nicht erklären. Es ist mir vollkommen unklar, was das soll.
Dieses Touch hier ist ganz schön schnell geworden, dieses Touch-ID. Es blockiert nicht mehr deinen Workflow. Ich weiß, das hört sich jetzt auch schon wieder nach Luxusproblemen an, aber das ist halt die halbe Sekunde, wo du dich denkst, so jetzt mach schnell.
Ja, wirklich draufklicken und gut. Der einzige Acht, der hat mich selbst schon beim 5S genervt, ist, du hast ja in diesem Log-Modus, hast ja diese Notifications, die da stehen. Das heißt, das Telefon brumselt dich an und stehen in den Notifications. Da stehen so Sachen drin, die man teilweise auch nicht wiederkriegt. Und dann versuchst du jetzt nur, diese Telefon zu wecken, indem du den Knopf antippst, aber dadurch, dass die Touch-Eddy so schnell ist, bist du sofort drin, diese ganzen Notifications sind alle weg und du denkst so, äh, ja.
Das heißt, du musst dir halt angewöhnen, jetzt bestimmte Sachen, wenn du den Knopf drücken willst, das mit dem Fingernagel zu machen, dass er dann nicht sofort dich einloggt.
Ja, wenn man es nicht haben will. Weil komischerweise, wenn man dann nämlich von oben nach unten runterzieht sollten, ja auch alle Notifications wiederkommen, kommen sie aber nicht. Nicht alle.
Dieses Streamer kommt durcheinander, wenn man von zwei Telefonen das gleiche Streamer-ID-Binks benutzt. Doch, bei mir schon. Das heißt, wenn ich eine Nachricht auf den einen abschicke, erscheint die auf dem anderen nicht.
Das ist ja auch kein iMessage. Ist nicht dafür gedacht, aber stirbt jetzt auch nicht. Stirbt jetzt kein Hellentod. Oder ich schick dir mal was. Wir können mal gucken, wo das ankommt bei dir. Jetzt Streamer.
Sind beide grün. Oh, nee, die zicken voll rum. Der eine geht raus, rein, dann fliegt der andere raus, dann fliegt der andere raus. Die wechseln sich immer ab.
Deswegen sollten wir den einen vielleicht mal machen.
Wenn ich beide Telefone jetzt hier so liegen lasse, ich glaube, dann löschen die mich irgendwann bei Streamer, weil der sich jetzt dauernd da kreuz und hin und her connectet.
Die wissen, dass es Leute gibt, die jetzt gerade von Telefon umstellen.
Na ja, vielleicht sollten sie in ihrer App dann auch einfach mal eine Message bringen.
Hast du eine konkrete Nachricht?
Ja, das ist jetzt auf dem alten Telefon gekommen, weil das gerade noch grün war und die kommt jetzt hier nicht. Der wird doch jetzt gerade hier nicht grün. Das ist doch scheiße.
Ich hab's aber jetzt von meinem alten Telefon auch nicht gekillt. Egal. Wir haben Sorgen, ne?
Ja, wir haben Sorgen.
Gut, ich denke die Einkaufsdiskussion ist durch. Aber da nehmen wir gerne noch weiteren Input entgegen.
Genau, das ist auf jeden Fall schön für ein bisschen Feedback.
Okay, Supermarkt-Layout und Routing. Tim könnte sich mal wieder über Podcasting unterhalten. Den geh ich aber erst mal vorher schnell. Weiß ich nicht.
Unix.
Was heißt denn Unix als Thema? Hast du dich jetzt entdeckt, dass es den Namen Unix gibt?
Ach so, ja, nee, keine Ahnung. Das sind eher so meine Notizen für den Fall, dass wir da irgendwie reinkommen.
Aber da kann ich jetzt nicht ein komplettes Gesprächsthemenkater aufmachen.
Ich hab übrigens doch irgendwie vor zwei, drei Sendungen mal von diesem Bread-Wallet erzählt, dieser Bitcoin-Wallet. Ich kriege das jetzt immer so ein bisschen rein. Wir haben gewohntes Durcheinander-Quatschen irgendwie hier in der Sendung traditionsmäßig aufrechterhalten. Und zwar jedenfalls, diese Bread-Wallet, habe ich ja gesagt, ist eine hierarchische Deterministik-Wallet, HD-Wallet. Und das heißt, ich habe hier, der hat ja alles hier rüber geschoben, habe diese Bread-Wallet gestartet, dann sagt er mir, es ist leer, willst du halt deine alte Wallet wieder herstellen? Hab ich gesagt, ja, alles klar, ich hoffe, ich habe die Keys wieder dabei, habe in dem anderen Fund gerufen, habe mir die Keys zeigen lassen, dann habt ihr die eingegeben. Hat er jetzt alles durchgesunken, schwupp, sind jetzt alle meine Bitcoins wieder da. Also man braucht von diesen Bread-Wallet außer... Na, die waren schon, die waren schon drin. Das sind meine, meine, meine Bitcoins.
Die waren wo drin? In deinem Backup waren die drin?
Nein, die sind... Also Bitcoins werden ja für dich gespeichert, indem du die Keys zu diesen Bitcoins hast. So und dieses Bread-Wallet sorgt ja durch diese HD-Wallet dafür, dass du halt dir die einzelnen 1000 Keys nicht merken musst, sondern dass du nur einen Key merken musst und alle anderen werden dann abgehend von diesem generiert. Deterministisch halt. Das heißt, ich musste mir einmal diese 12 Wörter merken, die er mir gegeben hat bei dem alten Telefon, hab die eingegeben, dann hat er das durchgesinkt, hat die ganze Blockchain irgendwie nach diesen Keys abgesucht, ob da nun Bitcoins drauf addiert wurden oder nicht und war jetzt fertig nach 5 Minuten und jetzt habe ich ja alle meine Bitcoins auch hier. Das lässt man einfach weg, weil du das nicht brauchst.
Manche Ups entscheiden sich bestimmte Daten, wie zum Beispiel Streamer, den Key, nicht in den backupfähigen Speicher reinzutun. Du kannst als Abentwickler entscheiden, ob der Müll, den du da hast, ob das temporary Tralala ist oder ob das was ist, was du gerne drauf aufgepasst haben möchtest vom IOS. Und manche Leute machen das entweder aus Dämlichkeit oder Faulheit oder eben absichtlich so, dass sie bestimmte Daten in den Temp-Space legen, das heißt, dass sie beim Telefonwechsel wieder neu generieren und von draußen reinladen müssen, also nicht aus dem Backup wiederkommen. Und das ist ja gerade das Interessante, wie gesagt, selbst Apple macht das. Ich hab da Keychained, alles war da, nur meine komischen S-Mime-Zertifikate samt Private Keys waren nicht da, die musste ich von Hand wieder drauflegen. Obwohl ich einen verschlüsselten iTunes-Backup gemacht habe. Sehr viele andere Daten, sehr viele andere Passwörter und so weiter, alle da waren, Keychain war da und so. Aber die Zertifikate hat er nicht mitgenommen. Oder eben dreimal den Key oder so ein paar andere Sachen, wo du denkst, äh, ich hab noch nicht genug gerentet. Ich hab noch ne Kleinigkeit, die würde ich gerne noch ansagen, weil ich es einfach toll finde. Das ist mein Lieblingsthema, IPv6. Muss ich mal kurz anschneiden. Leute fragen ja immer, wofür braucht man das als Firma zum Beispiel? Ich hab jetzt ein Incentive entdeckt. Ich hab jetzt für ein größeres Projekt, für einen Kunden mehrere Internetanschlüsse bei verschiedensten Firmen, Commerce, Business-Anschlüsse oder so was gehabt. Ich hatte auch einen, da gab es eine Twitter-Distruktion, wovon ich jetzt rede, ist jetzt nicht cold. Falls ihr das jetzt alle denkt und probiert, ist jetzt nicht cold. Aber es gibt auch andere Provider. Welche, die auch in Berlin und Brandenburg tätig sind, könnt ihr euch ja mal ausprobieren. Und da kommt eben so ein Anschluss. Da grinst sich dann halt so ein Ethernet-Kabel an, was da aus der Wand kommt. Und wenn du Glück hast, hängt da ein Zettel dran. So, hier sind ihre IP-Adressen. Guckt dann da drauf, sagt, das ist kein Jim Beam. Da stehen bloß IPv4-Adressen drauf. Ruft dann den Provider an und sagt so, hallo, 2015, hier fehlen auch die Angaben zu den IP-Adressen. Also hier stehen bloß V4-Adressen drauf. Und das Spannende ist, die Kriste wird dann auch geschaltet. Wie gesagt, im Gegensatz zu Colt. Deswegen gilt das jetzt nicht für Colt, weil ich sage. Aber was sie denn auch machen, ist, du merkst richtig an 1.003 Sachen, dass diese Provider, die sind entweder in, das haben wir noch nie so gemacht, das haben wir schon immer so gemacht oder dieses V6 ist ja nur, was für Nerds Modus ist. Die machen nämlich folgendes, wenn du Business-Internet-Anschlüsse kaufst, die kommen ja meistens, werden per Ethernet geliefert. Das heißt, du hast ein physikalisches Medium, was 100 Megabit oder ein Gig macht. Zehn macht keiner mehr. Das heißt, du kriegst so ein Kabel, steckst sie rein, dein Router sagt 100 Megabit, jetzt willst du aber nicht für 100 Megabit bezahlen. Das heißt, du kaufst jetzt nur, was ich für 10 Megabit. Was machen sie? Sie geben ja natürlich die Physik für einen 100 oder einen Gig sogar. Was machen sie? Sie drosseln halt. Sie haben halt irgendwo, machen sie das, dass du deinen Verkehr halt eben auf den Speed runter drosseln, den du kaufst. Und wenn du 25 Megabit kaufst, oder so.
Und vergesst das IPv6 zu drosseln?
Hab ich jetzt x-mal erlebt. Ich mach ein Speedtest drauf mit V4, zack, genau an den Anschlag ran, du kaufst 25 Megabit, 25 Megabit. Dann mach ich Speedtest mit V6, Paff, 100 Megabit, Paff-Gig. Da find ich das toll. Und das ist ein tolles Argument. Der Witz ist, das hab ich jetzt so häufig erlebt, dass wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel zu neuen Leuten hingehe, wie zum Beispiel zu Colt, die Colt-Leute haben natürlich, hab ich ja auch getwittert, haben mir da so blöde Fragen gestellt, wofür brauchen sie denn ein V6, hab ich denen gesagt, ja hallo, weil ich habe an anderen Standorten, hab ich 10-mal so viel Bandbreite für V6 wie V4. Ich hätt jetzt gerne V6. Also ich finde es deswegen toll, weil diese Arroganzen, das brauchen sie doch eh nicht, Typen, die einen immer so komisch angucken und dann übrigens auch komische Zettel schreiben, dann merkst du genau, dass die nie verstanden haben, was V6 ist. Das ist anders, die haben einfach ihre Formulare genommen und die mit einem Editor so find and replace ersetzt. Zum Beispiel hat man ja bei V4 immer noch das Thema, dass du auf einem Ethernet von einem IP-Netz immer die erste und letzte IP-Adresse nicht benutzen kannst. Klassiker ist, wenn du so einen Business-Anschluss hast, kriegst du einen Slash 29. Das sind normalerweise acht IP-Adressen. Die erste kannst du nicht benutzen, weil die Netzadresse ist. Die letzte kannst du nicht benutzen, weil die Broadcast-Adresse ist. Sie selber brauchen eine für ihren Router, also hast du als Kunde noch fünf übrig, die du benutzen kannst. Und die schreiben dann, habe ich die angemaut, habe gesagt, so hallo, das ist alles kack, das brauche ich nicht, ich brauche hier V6-Adressen. Schicken sie mir so einen Zettel, wo auch wieder drauf steht, ja, hier sind ihre V6-Adressen. Und die erste und die letzte können sie nicht benutzen. Und ich so zurück, doch kann ich benutzen. Hier ist der Standard, lest es nach. Aber dann merkst du halt wieder genau, die sind noch so diese alten, das haben wir schon immer so gemacht, denke und so und das finde ich halt schon...
Die erste von mehreren Millionen können sie nicht benutzen.
Nee, sie geben dir dann nur kleine Sachen auf den Transitnetz, die sind dann wirklich, die geben dir dann nur einen Slash 112. Also hast du dann nur 16 Bit für die Host da draussen. Das ist schon ein bisschen...
Man kann zu Hause keinen...
Du kriegst tatsächlich noch eine Prefix-Delegation für ein 48, das heißt, du hast dann 80 Bits, die du selber noch verwalten kannst. Aber jetzt auf dem Transitnetz kriegst du vorne, auf dem Link nach draußen geben sie dir nur ein 112 drauf, also da haben sie dann nur 65.536 Adressen.
Aber man kann hier Route Advertising machen und so und...
Nee, das machst du ja nicht auf dem Netz, sondern du holst entweder ein statisch zugewiesener Präfix, dass sie dir sagen, ja wir routen dir auf deine Adresse, routen wir da auch ein Slash 48 drauf. Oder du machst das halt so, wie sie die Großprovider, die Telekom, wo die dir dann noch ein Präfix einfach holen per DRCPv6. Das heißt, du klinkst dich ein, kriegst erstmal deine äußere Adresse, kriegst auch per Route Advertisement zugewiesen und dann sagst du, schön, dass du als Router jetzt eine Adresse nach draußen hab, ich möchte aber gerne für drinnen noch Adressen haben. Und die holt man sich dann per Präfix Delegation. Wir hatten das in dem übrigens inzwischen drei Jahre alten IPv6 CRE, hatten das besprochen und das ist jetzt ernsthaft so implementiert und wenn man ordentlich Equipment hat, geht das auch. Das heißt, du klemmst eine Fritzbox an, die holt sich von der Telekom in Slash 56 und du kannst jetzt hier noch hinter deine Fritzbox wieder eine andere Fritzbox oder einen anderen Router packen, der jetzt sagt, der jetzt die Fritzbox anbettelt, kann ich bitte auch noch ein paar Präfixe haben und diese ganze Chain klappert drunter. Und wenn du dann deine äußere Adresse wechselst, dann an der Präfix, klap, klap, klap, klap, klap, alle kriegen auch eine neue. Funktioniert.
As predicted. Ich überleg gerade, hat mir das überhaupt hier in der Sendung? Ich glaube, wir hatten irgendwie sowas...
Wir hatten eine Präfix-Delegation. Also wir hatten Zahngerissen.
Nein, in der Freak Show meine ich jetzt gerade neulich. Und zwar diese Geschichte, dass...
Ich war ja nicht da.
Nee, doch, das hast du ja noch erzählt. Ich hab mir gerade diese Geschichte mit Android gemacht, die Story, die du in der IETF mitgebracht hast.
Jetzt hab ich mich fünfmal im Kreis gesagt.
Das ist ja noch der andere Punkt. DRCPv6 hat halt mehrere Funktionen. Eine davon ist die Präfix-Delegation. Deswegen heißt es auch DRCPv6-PD, Präfix-Delegation, wo du dir ganze Netze zuweisen kannst, also Präfix-Adressbereiche zuweisen lassen kannst. Oder halt eben diese andere Funktion, wo man sagt, wie im IPv4, ich möchte mir jetzt nicht eine Adresse selber aussuchen, ich möchte gerne eine zugewiesen haben. Oder der Netzwerk-Admin sagt, du nimmst dir nicht selber eine, sondern du lässt dir eine zuteilen. So geht eigentlich die schwierige. Aber das fand ich irgendwie nett, also schaut mal drauf, Leute, die Business-Anschlüsse so haben, so diese typische Ding, so gedrosselte 100 Megabit oder gedrosselte Gigabit-Anschlüsse bei eurem jeweiligen Provider, macht doch da mal V6 an und guckt mal, ob die auch so gedrosselt werden. Aber verratet es denn keinem. Das finde ich jedenfalls sehr lustig.
So, ich bin jetzt eigentlich durch hier mit unseren Themen.
Ja, die Leute, die im Chat sagen, ich soll ansagen, dass es eine neue ZFS-Version für OS X gibt.
Also, ja, das sollte ich sagen.
Das stimmt. Und?
Ja, reicht ja schon. Weil da kam jetzt schon so lange nichts. Und manche haben ja vielleicht aufgehört, mal zu gucken. Ich hab mal ein bisschen durchgeguckt. Also da sind Features bei. Vielleicht sind auch manche wichtig. Ich weiß nicht so genau, aber alles nichts, wo ich jetzt wüsste, dass es irgendwie wichtig wäre. Also mir hat es bisher ja keine Probleme gemacht. Aber grundsätzlich kann das nicht schaden, wenn man das mal update.
ZFS, dem hab ich jetzt auch schon längere Zeit keine Liebe mehr geschenkt.
Keine Zeit gewidmet.
Ansonsten, Clemens, habe ich schon erzählt, dass der IPv6-Tunnel im iOS, den ich ja mache, jetzt auch IPv6 kann.
Der IPv6-Tunnel jetzt auch?
Der IPSEC-Tunnel, so rum.
Der IPv2 brauchst du dafür, damit das ordentlich funktioniert?
Nee, das vielleicht auch, aber die hatten halt einen Fehler in der iOS 8 irgendwie drin. Und seit 8.4 oder 8.4.1 hatten die das gefixt.
Ich werd's jetzt auch mal wieder austesten. Ich hab jetzt diese ganze IPSEC-Geschichte lange nicht angefasst, weil sie halt schon gelegentlich mal problembehaftet ist. Du hast dich ja bestritten in der Sendung. Du gehst aber auch nie in irgendwelche Faschornetze von irgendwelchen Hotels oder sowas. Es ist jetzt kein grundsätzlich Problem von der Technik. Ich bin halt jetzt in den letzten Wochen und Monaten doch immer mehr in meinem persönlichen Setup dem OpenVPN verfallen. Weil ich viel besser steuern kann und du kannst alles an dem Ding einstellen. Du kannst es eben auch so machen, dass es für eine Faschow-Firewire aussieht, als wäre das heute die PS-Verkehr. So, fertig, peng. Und ich transportiere da alles, inklusive auch Layer 2. Habe ich jetzt auch ein paar Mal gemacht. Leute, die jetzt in meinem beruflichen Umfeld da gerade umgezogen sind, mit ihrem Rechenzentrum, habe ich einfach mal die beiden Seiten gebritscht durch OpenVPN, inklusive VLANs und all so ein Zeug. Also das ist einfach ein sexy Swiss Army Knife für all solche Sachen. Und das gibt auch für das iPhone, also für iOS, gibt es auch eine kostenlose App, die das macht, die sich auch gut einbittet ins iOS. Also sie macht jetzt nicht irgendein Voodoo, sondern nutzt richtig diese VPN-Schnittstellen, die iOS da hat. Und das ist derzeit sozusagen mein heißer Scheiß. Weil ich das am besten auch steuern kann, auch Split-Tunnel-Techniken und so weiter und so fort. Das ist ja auch noch so ein Thema mit IKA V2, das müsste ich zum Beispiel jetzt erstmal gucken. Du weißt wovon ich rede, Split-Tunnel? Dass der Server dir sagt, schick mir nicht deinen ganzen Scheiß, sondern schick mir nur das für folgende IP-Adress rein. Dass du halt sagst, mein Internetverkehr geht ganz normal, nur der Verkehr in mein privates Netz hinten rein mit folgenden Adressen, V6, V4 soll da lang.
Was ich gerne hätte, dass er Adressen, die nach Rf 10, 19, 18 gehen, nicht durch den IP-Sec-Tunnel schicken. Das hätte ich gerne. Wenn ich in so einem lokalen Netz bin, sagen wir mal, Tim hat hier ein 10er Netz und ich will hier das Licht steuern, weil Tim hat Licht hier per IP, dann kann ich das nicht machen, weil mein IP-Sec irgendwie on demand für alles zählt und ich dann nicht mehr an den Lichtschalt herankomme.
Aber wenn Tim hier ein zweites Netz hätte, dann hast du ein Problem. Wenn Tim jetzt hier 192.168.1.20 benutzt, MV4, und seine Lichtsteuerung auf 192.168.42.0 ist klar, dann gehen die Dinge da durch.
Ja, das mit den beiden Netzen muss ich nochmal checken. Das kann sein, dass es da, wo ich Probleme hatte, dass es zwei Netze waren. Das stimmt schon, muss ich nochmal...
Das lokale Netz bleibt immer lokal. Ja, all solche Sachen, das finde ich halt eben schön, dass auf der OpenVPN-Seite kann ich das selber steuern und zwar sowohl auf dem Server als auch im Kleinen, als auch für V6 wie V4, als auch für Ethernet mit Tralala und so und so und scharf. Und man kann das auch schön skripten, das ist eben auch ganz nett. Der einzige Nachteil ist wahrscheinlich der, der viele Leute von OpenVPN abschreckt, ist eine der längsten Manpages, die es gibt für irgendwelche Tools. Weil das Ding halt dräuft sich tausend Optionen hat. Wenn man sich aber mal die Muße nimmt und sich mal eine Stunde oder zwei Stunden Zeit nimmt, dieses ganze Manpage einmal durchzulesen, einfach nur um zu wissen, dass es da was gibt. Da kann man ja hinterher immer noch die Details sich angucken oder so.
Wie heißt die App, die du nochmal meinst?
Das ist OpenVPN. kann man einfach nachsuchen. Wie sieht die aus? Die sieht so ein bisschen orange-ig aus. Also wie das Icon Achso, sie hat übrigens auch noch einen Punkt, das konntest du auch schon ewig. Wenn du die anmachst, die bleibt an. Ja, also auch wenn du jetzt wechselst, wenn du zwischen WLAN und LTE oder so was hin und her wechselst und so, die bleibt halt an, reconnectet dich und wenn du deinen Server ordentlich aufgesetzt hast, behältst du auch deine IP-Adresse. Das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Sex. Das heißt, wenn du das anmachst, entweder jetzt ich mach das ja nur für bestimmte Privat-Sachen, ich hab aber auch Profile, die mir den Gesamtverkehr rüber routen, also typisch, ich möchte jetzt meinen ganzen Verkehr irgendwie in Holland oder in den USA abkippen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann geht das auch. Und du kannst den eigentlichen Carrier darunter, also ob das WLAN ist oder LTE, selbst zwischen den verschiedenen Netzen, ja genau, zwischen denen hin und her. Um das Icon zu beschreiben, ist so ein Oranger-Kreis mit so einem blauen Mannequin drin oder ein Schlüsselloch oder sowas, das ist eine so eine OpenVPN-App. Die sieht am Anfang ein bisschen komisch aus, weil der Hersteller oder der Typ, der die Leute abvertreiben, bieten auch gleichzeitig Tunnel damit an, die man sich da gleich klicken kann. Also wer jetzt keinen Bock hat, selber einen Server aufzusetzen, sondern nur den üblichen, ich brauche einen Ami-Tunnel, damit ich irgendwelche Content angucken kann, die mir die Deutschen nicht zeigen oder sowas, kann das da gleich mitmachen. Du kannst aber einfach so ein Konfig-File für OpenVPN, könnten wir übrigens auch mal in so einer Sendung besprechen, so Crypto Follow Masses. Aber nicht mehr heute. Kannst du ein Konfig-File machen, das schickst du dir selber per Mail zu, klickst dann in deinem Mail-Programm drauf und dann wird es übertragen in diese OpenVPN ab und gut ist. Und wie gesagt, ich schätze es halt sehr, ich weiß halt sehr genau, was ich will und was ich haben will, ob ich jetzt UDP, TCP-Encapsulation haben will oder wie auch immer. Und ich baue mir da meine Profile zusammen, wie ich sie brauche und bin nicht darauf angewiesen, dass jetzt irgendwelche Sachen da wieder mal nicht implementiert sind von Apple oder doch oder so. Finde ich halt eigentlich ganz sexy. Und dass sie eben anbleibt. So viel dazu. Aber ich will jetzt nicht heißen, dass jetzt Ipsac oder gerade IKE 2 ist eine schöne Sache, ist sehr ordentlich, ist auch schön strukturiert und so kann man auch lustige Sachen mitmachen. Aber ist halt so ein bisschen gelenklich ärgerlich.
Ich bin durch.
Ich hab mal gar nichts mehr, nicht mal so kleine Mini-Dinger, wo man nur so ein paar Sekunden erzählt, wie gibts das, jenes, dort neue Updates, irgendwas.
Du, da sind wir ja schon längst dabei, wenn dir da was einfällt.
Was sind denn so meine Standardthemen?
Aber ich muss heute ein bisschen früher Schluss machen.
Verstehe, morgen ist wieder Bitcoin, Donnerstag in Room 77, ich mach ja da gerne Werbung.
Heißt was?
In Friedrich da würd ich auch gerne Werbung machen, da gab's halt Kohlrohladen, aber ich konnte ja heute nicht. Ich wurde aber nachrichtig, es gibt Kohlrohladen.
Echt, da kriegst du ne Push-Notification oder was?
Nee, ne SMS. Na, ne iMessage wahrscheinlich, er hat ja auch ein iPhone.
Das hätt ich auch gern. Kohlrohladen. Wir machen ne kurze Sendung heute.
Ja, ich sag, gut, geh ich noch ne Runde tanzen.
Genau, es geht noch ein bisschen tanzen. Übrigens hat ein Hörer oder eine Hörerin darauf hingewiesen, dass nicht nur bei der IETF gesummt wird.
Sondern auch bei?
Bei Giraffens Zuhause.
Genau, bei Giraffen wird auch gesummt.
Ist erstaunlich.
Soll ich das mal anspielen? Was denn das?
Ah, hier.
Giraff spend their evenings humming to each other.
Hört man da was?
Nee, ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Nee, die kommunizieren wohl irgendwie so abends miteinander.
Aber jetzt hab ich auch wieder mein Echo.
Oh, hallo Clemens.
Man weiß zumindest, wo das Echo herkommt.
Von den Grafen.
Oder?
Und ansonsten für alle Amazon-Wunschlisten, Schenker noch mal vielen Dank. Da kam letztens wieder was und da bedanke ich mich.
Herzlich. Heydo.
Ich bedanke mich auch. So, jetzt summ'en wir euch in den Schlaf. Gibt ja gar nichts heute.
Nicht mal ausmachen kann er.
Das ist echt zu mollen.
Das fix ich jetzt einfach mal.
Während der Sendung.
Ja klar.
Ich bin Experte.
Und irgendwie ist mir das halt ein...
Schon habe die Sendung so viel. Das fix ich jetzt mal.
Ist mir egal, ich fixe das jetzt mal.
Genau ist mir egal, ich fixe das jetzt einfach mal. 25, 26, wieso kommt mir der dann auf der 14 rein? Das ist doch wirklich echt zum Heulen.
25, 26, dann mache ich das mal an.
War eine sehr friedliche Sendung, ne?
Aber jetzt habe ich wieder Echo. Na, dann muss ich ja unsere Mikrofone ausmachen und dann... Aber so ist es eigentlich auch ganz gut mit dem Summen, oder?